Es tut mir leid, es ist vorbei.
Schön, dass du es sagst.
Und der nächste
zufällige Podcast in eurem
Podcatcher beginnt in 3,
2, 1.
Gut.
Sende.
Hab ich noch aufgenommen?
Das ist schwer.
Hi Kilian.
Hi Hendrik.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 29.
So weit sind wir schon.
Ja, wir müssen das jetzt feiern.
Das ist das letzte Mal in den 20ern.
Hart.
Danach wird es bitter.
Da denke ich noch nicht drüber nach.
Das geht mir noch zu weit.
Und ich habe hier so Shownotes vorbereitet.
Habe ich Notes vorbereitet?
Shownotes vorbereitet?
Ich dachte, die schreiben wir live on air.
Nee, ja.
So live, wie unsere Folgen rausgehen.
Also wir hatten uns das letzte Mal auf dem Mobile Camp getroffen und hatten überlegt,
ob wir da kurz eine Folge aufnehmen und dann gesagt haben, ach nee, lass uns lieber hier mit Leuten reden.
Und ich habe aber ein bisschen mitgeschrieben, was da so passiert ist.
Du bist ja krass produktiv.
Ich hätte das vielleicht nicht sagen sollen.
Nee, sehr cool.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ich mich auf dem Mobile Camp offiziell angemeldet hatte.
Und nicht einfach nur zufällig dreigeschneid.
Normalerweise war das ja so, dass ich, also das Mobile Camp ist so ein Barcamp in Dresden.
Das ist einmal im Jahr so ein Wochenende an der Informatikfakultät.
Und das ist immer so ein Wochenende gewesen bis dato, wo ich einfach mal so in die Informatikfakultät gegangen bin früher,
weil ich ja fast nebenan gewohnt habe.
Und dann bin ich da mal hin und dachte mir, ich hole mir einfach mal fix eine Mate und dann gehe ich in den großen Garten oder sowas aus dem Aski.
Und dann war aber immer Barcamp, aber dann bin ich im Endeffekt immer dort geblieben.
Mach dir ruhig deine Flasche auf.
Diesmal habe ich...
Oh, jetzt.
Es ist super weird zu trinken,
wenn du die dazu geröhrige
Geräuschkulisse machst.
Diesmal wusste ich schon vorher Bescheid,
wenn mir irgendjemand davon erzählt hat.
Eventuell sogar Sascha.
Hi Sascha.
Und ich hatte mich angemeldet, deswegen habe ich
so ein T-Shirt, aber ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo ich das habe.
Der bekommt jeder so ein T-Shirt, der da mitmacht.
Und es ist halt Barcamp, gehst hin,
meldest dich an und dann
kannst du sagen, hier, ich könnte über das oder das reden.
Und Sascha hat irgendwie drei Vorträge gehalten.
Dieser Sascha.
Ja, ich habe mir auch zu einem davon ein paar Notizen gemacht.
Ich glaube, den müssten wir einfach mal in die Sendung holen.
Das ist auch der Typ, der sich beschwert hat,
dass wir schon wieder fast einen Monat keine Folge gemacht haben.
Und er eine ganze Dienstreise nach Schweden machen musste,
ohne eine Folge akronomisierbar auf den Ohren.
Hart.
Das ist schon...
Ich sag dir ein, Sascha,
ich fühle mit dir.
Das ist immer schwer.
Ein paar Vorträge waren ganz cool.
Einer hat zum Beispiel einen zum Thema
Audioaufnahmen gemacht.
Ah, stimmt.
Der war extrem voll besucht und sehr detailliert
und hat den Zeitrahmen komplett
gesprengt, woraufhin er gesagt hat,
ich halte einfach morgen die zweite Hälfte.
Und dementsprechend hat er quasi
zwei Vorträge gehalten und er hat
das sehr schön gemacht. Er hat einfach sein gesamtes
Soundsetup da, hatte Laptop, hatte irgendwie Q-Base,
gutes Mikrofon, Lautsprecher.
Und dann hat er in dieses Mikrofon
reingesprochen, hatte so ein Pop-Filter
davor und hat gesagt, das ist ein
Pop-Filter, Pop-Pop-Pop-Pop-Filter.
Und hat er gezeigt, was zum Beispiel so ein Pop-Filter
für einen Unterschied auf der Aufnahme macht. Dann hat er noch so ein bisschen
über andere Sachen geredet. Niemals mit
zu viel Gain aufnehmen.
Und nur wegen diesem Talk klingen wir heute
übrigens so gut. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich genau in die ganzen Sachen geheilt habe. Bei mir ist es ja so,
ich habe mir dann gedacht, ah ja genau,
ich muss mich dann gleich mal hinsetzen und
mit meinem Aufnahmesetup nochmal so richtig rumspielen.
Aber im Endeffekt mache ich das dann mal erst,
wenn du schon vor der Tür stehst und wir uns über die ersten Sachen unterhalten
und ich denke, scheiße, schnell ist Aufnahme starten.
Ja, ihr kennt das gar nicht, wie das ist, mit Hendrik zu reden.
Man kann gar nicht nochmal mit ihm sprechen, weil es so vielleicht,
ja, darüber sollten wir doch bestens erst reden,
wenn ein Mikrofon zwischen uns steht.
Das ist schlimm, ich habe ja ein bisschen den Verdacht,
dass sich so Leute wie die beiden Hosts von Methodisch Unkorrekt
eigentlich nur noch auf Band miteinander unterhalten.
Das ist bei uns auch fast ein bisschen so,
aber wir werden ja demnächst fast Nachbarn sein
und da können wir vielleicht auch mal wieder
in so einem lockeren Rahmen unterhalten.
Ich bin fast von der neuen Wohnung hierher gefahren gerade eben.
Ja?
Also fast.
Wie läuft neuer Umzug?
Zieht sich.
Also wir haben viel gestrichen.
Oh Gott, der war völlig unbeabsichtig.
Ich habe den jetzt nicht mehr gehört.
Oh Mann, ja.
Ja, also euer Umzug zieht sich?
Oh Gott.
ja, ja, vermutlich
in zwei Wochen ist alles getan.
Cool.
Dann wohnen wir hier.
Habt ihr schon Nachmieter für die alte Bude gefunden?
Ja, gestern war nochmal, also wir haben ein paar Besichtigungen
gehabt, also nicht, dass wir uns drum kümmern,
aber Vermieterin schickt jemanden
vorbei, der sich mal die Wohnung anschauen möchte.
Achso. Immer ganz nett.
Cool, dann macht sie das ja
fast von alleine.
Ja, da gibt es
auch nicht so viel Interessantes
sozusagen. Das ist ein Umzug
innerhalb der Stadt.
Was ich, ach, hier kann ich mal was sagen
dazu, was mir wirklich aufgefallen ist, was ich
kacke finde, worauf ich,
wo es mich genervt hat, dass ich
nicht selber drauf gekommen bin, aber dass
ich auch nicht darauf hingewiesen wurde.
Und zwar habe ich mich
letzte Woche
vor zwei Wochen umgemeldet
bei der Stadt,
weil wir offiziell quasi
in der neuen Wohnung wohnen, auch wenn wir da noch nicht
wirklich physisch wohnen, aber offiziell
schon.
Und habe festgestellt,
dass, also ich habe mich umgemeldet,
war alles okay, mit Ummeldung halt,
wie man das so macht, man geht hin, man sagt, wo man wohnt,
man hat einen Zettel dabei, der wird abgestempelt, fertig.
Drei Tage später hat sie meine Freundin
umgemeldet und sie meinte,
sie hatte nochmal gefragt wegen den
Stadtratswahlen, die wir jetzt in Dresden hatten und
der Europawahl, von der wir wahrscheinlich alle
wissen, aber wir hatten in Dresden auch noch Kommunalwahlen,
Stadtrat bzw. Stadtbezirksbeirat und
außerhalb auch Orts irgendwas.
Und du durftest nicht wählen.
Und ich habe mit dem Umzug Erfolg meine Stimme für die Stadtbezirksbeiratswahl verloren.
Das finde ich ziemlich kacke.
Das hat mir ein anderer Bekannter, der gerade umzieht, auch erst erzählt.
Also Stadtbezirkswahl?
Und hast du gewählt?
Nee, denn ich bin letzten Monat umgezogen oder so.
Also wir sind dann direkt nochmal, nachdem meine Freundin das mitbekommen hatte,
zum Wahlamt gefahren.
Da war natürlich völlig überfüllt der Laden,
da wo man die Briefwahlunterlagen auch physisch abholen kann
und gleich wieder abgeben kann.
Briefwahl halt?
Briefwahl, genau. Man geht hin, man treibt Kreuzvers an,
man gibt es ab. Aber man geht zwischendurch einmal raus
mit dem Zettel, weil direkt dort ausführen geht natürlich nicht.
Das wäre ja keine Briefwahl.
Echt jetzt? Ja, du musst einfach rausgehen.
Also du kannst dich abholen
und dann stellst du dich in eine andere Schlange
nochmal ganz von draußen, um es abzugeben.
Achso, ich wollte gerade sagen, das letzte Mal, als ich das gemacht habe,
das war wie einfach
wählen gehen. Das war genau so eine Kabine
und sowas. Also du musst nochmal aus dem Raum
rausgehen, um dich in die 300 Meter
lange Schlange anzustellen. Die geht dann zu den Ohren
wieder vor und du hast die ganze Zeit deine
in der Hand schon und dann bist du wieder vorne.
Hast du auf den Wahlunterlagen irgendwelche Bekannten
wieder getroffen?
Ich habe ein paar Leute wiedererkannt, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, worauf du hier auch...
Ich war überrascht, dass ein alter Schulfreund von mir
plötzlich irgendwie wählbar war.
Nice. Aber nee, wir haben die
dann erstmal mitgenommen, haben da erstmal
nachgefragt gehabt. Ja, ist korrekt.
Stadtbezirksbeiratswahl, die Stimmen sind jetzt
flöten. Super, cool.
Aber wir sehen noch nicht drei Monate in einem neuen Bezirk wohnen.
Diskriminiert Leute, die
in Wahljahren umziehen, ne?
Ja, aber ich habe da auch zusätzlich noch später erst rausgefunden, dass man wohl, wenn man innerhalb von 21 Tagen von der Wahl umzieht, in seinem alten Bezirk doch noch irgendwie wählen darf.
Aber davon habe ich dann auch nichts Passendes gefunden.
Die wollen einfach nicht, dass Leute wählen, die es sich einen Umzug leisten können.
Ja, aber ist das nicht eher im Interesse der Politik?
Keine Ahnung.
Das sind ja gerade die Unionswähler, oder?
Und vor allem FDP-Wähler.
Ich bin, viele Leute, die ich kenne oder gefragt habe, haben gesagt,
nee, ich habe schon längst gewählt, ich habe ja Briefwahl gemacht und so.
Und ich dachte, ich gebe mir einfach mal den Spaß,
weil ich mag das irgendwie sonntags hier vor der Tür zu gehen.
Da sind plötzlich Leute auf der Straße.
Das heißt eigentlich nur an Wahltagen.
Und dann gehst du zu dieser Schule hin, da sind auch plötzlich Leute.
Dann stehst du mal wieder in einem Schulgang.
Das ist ja witzig, in so ein Gymnasium weiter zu lassen.
Auch so, aha, ja, Weile her.
Und ich habe das so ein bisschen
vertwittert, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich stand da echt fast 40 Minuten
an, bis ich hier rangekommen bin.
Da gab es irgendwie, es gibt immer
fünfstellige Zahlen,
welche Gruppe von
Wählern du bist. Und dann kommst du rein,
also da drei von diesen Gruppen.
Und hinten die letzten drei Zahlen
nennen sich bloß 100, 200, 300.
Bezirk oder irgendwas.
Und ich habe geguckt,
da gab es eine Riesenschlange,
das war meine Nummer, und dann gab es die beiden
aller Nummer, da standen jeweils bloß so zehn Leute
an. Super. Ganz toll.
Sind das die Frühaufsteher gewesen, die schon
da waren alle oder was? Und ich stehe jetzt hier bei denen.
Der Rentnerbezirk ist schon durch. Genau, vor mir
stand einer so ein,
ich würde mal in meiner Sprache
Atze sagen, mit so einem großen Pegida-Button
irgendwie auf seiner Lederweste.
Ich habe gedacht,
okay, geht bitte alle
wählen, habe ich dann getwittert.
Könnt ihr mal verraten, was der Typ vor mir ankreuzt.
Ja, und dann
habe ich mir ein Kreuzchen gemacht und
hat nichts gebracht und dann...
Wie hat nichts gebracht?
Du kannst ja das Wahlergebnis in Dresden bekommen.
Ich finde die Resultate, also die Dresdner Wahlergebnisse
sind zwar ein bisschen interessant, aber ich muss sagen,
ich bin mit den Resultaten bis auf dem Zuwachs
rechts echt zufrieden.
Also ich finde, der Unionseinbruch
ist fantastisch, der SPD-Einbruch fantastisch.
Ich habe mir ein bisschen mehr gewünscht,
aber die Union hat ja europaweit,
für die Europawahl in Deutschland,
je schlechtestes Ergebnis ever.
Ja, ich glaube, dieser
Rezo-Moment hat wahrscheinlich was gebracht.
Das fand ich großartig. Richtig gutes Timing für das Video.
Echt schön gemacht.
Das war auch so ein Ding, auf dem wir uns auf dem Mobile Camp unterhalten hatten.
Ihr habt dieses Video schon geguckt?
Ich so, nee, wer ist das?
Und ich hab von dem Typen vorher noch nie gehört.
Meine Freundin schaut den schon länger.
Der ist bekannter YouTuber.
Der ist sogar Informatiker.
Ja, der hat ein Diplom in Informatik.
Der hat ein Diplom in Informatik.
Nee, sorry, Masterabschluss hat er.
Aber äquivalent.
Genau.
Künstliche Intelligenz hat er da geschrieben für seine Arbeit.
Hat er da mal gemeint, glaube ich.
Also warte mal, der ist also quasi auf dem gleichen Level wie wir,
aber die Sprache, die der in diesem Video an den Tag ist...
Er ist halt YouTuber und er ist halt vor allem Musiker.
Also er ist exakt, er ist du quasi,
bloß dass du keine blauen Haare hast.
Wollte mir aber vielleicht ganz gut sagen.
Also würdest du dir die Haare blau aufwärmen
und anfangen YouTube-Videos zu machen,
dann seid ihr literally dieselbe Person.
Ja lol, ey.
Aber der ist auch echt begabter Musiker,
was der da manchmal für Kram macht.
Ich muss mir sein Feed erstmal erarbeiten.
Danach kam ja nochmal so ein Aufruf von 70 YouTubern.
Also ich bin auch echt Jack-N-Kinder-YouTuber-State überhaupt nicht drin.
Ich muss sagen, ich kannte keinen davon.
Ich gebe zu, ich gucke sehr viel YouTube, aber ich kenne nicht einen deutschen YouTuber.
Okay, ich gucke null YouTube, hin und wieder mal ein Video, was mir irgendjemand schickt.
Meine Freundin ziemlich viel.
Und wir haben uns das Video halt zusammen angeschaut.
Und sie meinte, ja, die Person, die Person, die Person, die Person, die kennt die, glaube ich, drei nicht.
Und ich so, ja, den Namen kenne ich.
Den schaust du doch auch manchmal.
Und die da auch.
Ich finde mich cool, weil ich fünf, sechs Leute kannte.
Ich finde, wir hätten so einen Podcaster-Aufruf
machen müssen.
Das hat bestimmt dieselbe Reichweite.
Ja, da kennst du auch die ganzen Gesichter, nicht?
Stimmt, sogar noch besser,
voll unparteiisch und so.
Die Stimme,
was die Augen zu. Ach, das ist doch der Britlove.
Nee, aber
das Wahlergebnis, wie gesagt, ich finde es echt
schön, wie, also dass man auch
tatsächlich, ich meine, diese ganze Fridays-for-Future-Bewegung
steht ja auch mit dahinter, dass man auch sieht,
dass man mit seinen Stimmen was anfangen kann.
Hätte die Union uns dasselbe Ergebnis wie immer eingefahren.
und die Grünen sonst wo gelegen.
Ich meine, auch die Grünen haben scheiße verkackt bisher,
die sind auch nicht die beste Partei,
aber es ist ein riesen Unterschied zur Union.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach mal Platzhalter-mäßig Union gegenüber Grüne stelle,
als das, was wir eigentlich beeinflussen haben,
gesehen wollten mit dieser Wahl.
Wir wollten, dass die Union fällt und die Grünen steigen,
ganz grob zusammengefasst.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Und hoffentlich motiviert das Leute auch,
ihre Stimmen weiterhin in Zukunft zu haben zu geben,
weil sie halt merken, dass sowas bringt.
Ich meine, in Dresden haben wir natürlich noch das Problem,
dass die AfD recht stark dazugewonnen hat,
beziehungsweise generell die Rechten ein bisschen zugenommen, auch europaweit.
Man muss halt dazu wissen, Sachsen ist halt auch die AfD-Hochburg
und so schlimm wie es hier ist, ist es halt sonst nirgends.
Aber ich fände es auch schön, gerade für die Stadtratswahl,
die hatten wir ja auch, die Kommunalwahlen,
wenn man halt die Ergebnisse mal angeschaut hat,
wie sie sich im Laufe des Abends noch entwickelt haben.
Zuerst war die AfD wirklich die stärkste Partei in Dresden
und das war halt schon ein bisschen erschreckend für den Stadtrat.
Und dann sind sie halt gefallen, gefallen, gefallen,
irgendwann sogar hinter die Union gefallen.
Hast du das Ergebnis gerade irgendwie vor dir?
Die sind sogar hinter die Union gefallen.
Die Grünen sind dann plötzlich die stärkste Partei.
Wir haben jetzt wirklich mit dem guten Vorlauf
die Grünen als stärkste Partei im Stadtrat.
Das finde ich großartig.
Dann habe ich zu früh das letzte Mal hingeguckt.
Also es sind glaube ich,
ah ne, Stadtbezirks...
Oh ja, jetzt wird es kompliziert.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Das ist schon der Stadtrat, aber es gab...
Ah, genau, im Stadtrat sind...
Da gab es ja schon einen schönen Fuck-up hier lokal.
Ich entschuldige mich hiermit offiziell bei unseren ganzen Nicht-Dresdner-Zuhörern.
Ein bisschen Kommunalergebnisse sind ja immer ganz nett.
Auf jeden Fall.
Die höre ich mir auch anderswo gerne an.
Aber mir geht es eigentlich bloß daran, dass es einen witzigen Fuck-Up noch gab,
dass die irgendwie in zwei Wahlbezirken der Wahlausschuss aufgelöst,
bevor sie fertig ausgezählt hatten.
So, ich habe genug, ich gehe jetzt nach Hause.
Ich weiß nicht, was da passiert ist.
Ich glaube, die müssen eine Mindestanzahl von Personen sein, vermute ich mal.
Vielleicht ist es auch irgendwann zu wenig gewesen.
Irgendwer ist ja wohl gegangen oder irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Und die haben sich halt, wie gesagt, dementsprechend aufgelöst, konnten nicht fertig auszählen.
Und rechtlich gesehen darf das jetzt keiner auszählen, bis in zwei Wochen irgendwie der Gemeindewahlausschuss oder sowas ähnliches eingeladen und zusammengekommen ist.
Und die dürfen das dann auszählen.
Das heißt, wir haben wirklich erst in zwei Wochen oder so.
Das absolut ist das Ergebnis.
Genau, aber es sind nur zwei Wahlbezirke von 500.
Da sind jetzt übelst viele AfD-Stimmen dabei.
Wir haben 500 Wahlbezirke oder 540, das sind zwei.
Also das ändert wahrscheinlich nichts an den Zahlen.
aber es ist trotzdem witzig, dass sowas passiert.
Kennst du irgendjemanden, der Wahlhelfer war?
Dirk, wie immer.
Cool.
Ich kann das laut aussprechen, weil er es vertwittert hat.
Stefan Majewski.
Hey, sehr cool.
Der hat Fotos von großen Stapeln von,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das durfte,
aber von großen Stapeln von Wahlzetteln.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch,
und habe es dann irgendwie verkackt,
mich dafür anzumelden und irgendwie mitzumachen.
Nachdem ich das letzte Mal schon irgendwie
bekannte Gesichter auf diesen Werdet-Wahlhelfer-Postern gesehen habe.
Tenji Hara, der in ganz Dresden
ist super cool. Also ein Dozent
von der Uni.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir,
das muss ich eigentlich auch mal machen.
Dieses Amt ist ja auch direkt um die
Ecke von meinem Arbeitsplatz. Da könnte ich
einfach mal hingehen. Und zack, waren die Wahlen vorbei
und ich dachte mir, ach Mensch, da wollte ich doch was machen.
Also ich spreche natürlich auch als
Hippocrat, weil ich es nicht selber gemacht habe, aber es sollten generell
mehr Leute machen. Und ich fände es auch cool, wenn das
natürlich Leute machen. Und ich fände es auch cool, wenn ich es mache.
Habe ich vielleicht das letzte Mal schon erzählt, ich hätte ja
Kneipenquiz organisiert. Und da war eine der
die ich gestellt habe, wie viele Wahlhelfer
werden gesucht?
Werden gesucht?
Werden gesucht auf Dresden.de.
Frage war,
für die kommenden Europa- und
Kommunalwahlen sucht die Stadt Dresden
Wahlhelfer.
Wie viele werden insgesamt gebraucht?
Wie viele werden insgesamt gesucht?
Und 1.000, 2.000 oder 4.000?
Ich tippe mal auf die größtmögliche 4.000.
Das waren 4.000.
Ich habe beim Kneipenquiz Werbung dafür gemacht,
Wahlhelfer zu werden.
Vielleicht reitet mich das so ein bisschen aus der Scheiße.
Aber ja, cool
Es besteht also noch so ein bisschen Hoffnung
Ja, ansonsten
die Ergebnisse, die ich halt noch mitteilen möchte
weil ich da immer sehr stolz drauf bin, ist
die Verteilung in meinem aktuellen
noch Wahlbetreiber
Kreis, shit, was ist denn das?
Mein Gebiet? Gegend
Ja, mein Stadtteil
Keine Ahnung, mein Kiez
Das sagt man hier echt selten in Dresden
hab ich das Gefühl
Nee, ist auch nicht Hamburg
Nee, aber da, wo ich halt aktuell wohne, weil in der Dresdner Neustadt die Wahlergebnisse mir immer direkt aus dem Herzen sprechen. Also wir haben für den Stadtbezirksbeirat, wo das halt wirklich spezifisch dann für die jeweiligen Teile ist, man kann auch natürlich die anderen Ergebnisse in den jeweiligen Kreisen anschauen, aber für den Stadtbezirksbeirat, stellvertretend 34 Prozent für die Grünen, 23 Prozent für die Linken und alles andere unter 10.
Das ist großartig.
Wir hatten ja glaube ich damals, ich weiß gar nicht mehr welche Wahl,
das war irgendeine Bundestagswahl glaube ich vor,
die letzte oder die davor,
wo ich auch noch Pirat war damals,
da hatten wir in der Neustadt das beste
kommunale Wahlergebnis,
also nicht kommunale, aber das beste
Wahlkreisergebnis für die Piraten
in ganz Deutschland eingefahren.
Das fand ich fantastisch.
Wenn du Pirat bist, dann ist das ja passiert.
Das fand ich großartig.
Ich stand nie zur Wahl da.
Ich stand einmal für die Stadtrat zum Wahl
in Dresden.
Du bist das nicht geworden.
Nee, ich habe 270 Stimmen bekommen.
277, das waren 274 Stimmen mehr als der NPD-Kandidatin.
Der hatte drei, wahrscheinlich seine drei.
Wer zum Geier wählt in der Neustadt NPD?
Nee, das war im Dings-Zellischer Weg Wunschstraße.
Ach so, dann gibt es vielleicht den einen oder anderen.
Also es gab tatsächlich, wie gesagt, nur drei Stimmen für den NPD-Kandidaten.
Also ich vermute mal.
Er, seine Frau und seine Tochter.
Man hatte drei Stimmen in der Wahl.
Also wahrscheinlich er selber.
Ach so, er hat sich selbst gewählt.
Ich vermute mal, er hat sich selbst gewählt.
Ach so, das stimmt.
Das passt einfach zu stehen, wenn es genau drei sind.
Gut,
haben wir dieses Wahlthema, glaube ich,
vollends beackert.
Hast du noch auf dem Mobile Camp
auch welche coolen Talks, Jan, gehört?
Wir sagten ja in fast keinem
gemeinsam. Was habe ich denn angeschaut
gehabt? Ein bisschen zu
Augmented Reality-Krams, obwohl
da jetzt nichts Spezifisches dabei war, bloß jemand,
der von IBM, einer,
der ein bisschen Spaß gehabt hatte,
mit den iOS-Frameworks rumzuspielen,
beziehungsweise
mit den iOS-Frameworks rumzuspielen, zu merken,
dass eben die nicht so wirklich taugen und dann mit
IBM-Frameworks rumzuspielen.
Und,
naja, ich meine, es läuft ja auch anscheinend on-device.
Ich habe die anderen ausprobiert und so ist es doch besser.
Ich meine, es läuft trotzdem,
es ist Core-ML-Krams,
der on-device läuft, aber
das Model hat ja in der IBM-Cloud
antrainiert. Ich meine, es spricht natürlich
nichts dagegen, wenn er das so machen möchte, vor allem, weil er
IBM-Mitarbeiter ist und das auch...
Was für Models hat man sonst zur Auswahl? Gibt es da welche,
die man von Apple bekommen kann?
Oh, da fragst du mich was. Ich meine, Apple gibt ein paar,
hier ist Beispielkram,
das tun dir was, aber da ist jetzt
nichts Spezifizier, ansonsten kannst du,
es ist ja auch,
sehr Use-Case-abhängig. Hier begebe ich mich in Gewässer, von denen ich wieder
wenig Ahnung habe, aber es gibt doch diese...
Achso, ich dachte, von denen du nicht erzählen darfst.
Das wäre jetzt spannend.
Von CoreML habe ich Apple intern nicht viel mitbekommen.
Es gab ein paar Mailinglisten, wo Leute was rumgeschrieben haben, aber
da war jetzt nichts, wo ich
groß was mitgenommen hätte.
was mir aber noch einfällt
war doch, dass man
ja, fällt mir der Begriff dafür nicht mal ein
wenn du nicht bei Null anfängst
um ein Model anzutrainieren, sondern quasi
auf sowas wie Bilderkennung
ist schon komplett drin, auf dem Level anfängst
und dann antrainierst hier das in verschiedenen
Handgesten oder so
sowas ist schon vorgegeben
also sowas bietet dir QML auch direkt mit
dass du halt da dieses
ich kenne die Begrifflichkeit
ich bekomme gerade das
die Eingabe, wir sollten vielleicht mal jemanden einladen,
der sich damit auskennt, aber dann wird das
so eine Folge, wo der dann wieder alleine redet.
Wir sitzen nicken daneben.
Faszinierend.
Ich hoffe, unsere Zuhörer verstehen das, weil ich verstehe das nicht.
Wir sollten zu vielen
Dingen die Leute einladen, aber es macht uns als Podcast
doch auch aus, dass wir so breit gefächert sind,
ohne Ahnung zu haben.
Ich meine,
man kennt ja diesen Begriff des T-shaped developers,
also wie so ein T,
aber im Sinne von Wissen. Du hast ein breites
Grundwissen und ein
Gebiet, wo es halt wirklich richtig tief reingeht.
Der Stil von dem T.
Wenn du zwei hast, dann bist du pie-shaped?
Nice. Und wir sind mehr wie so ein umgekehrter Rasen-shaped.
Wir haben überall so ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Aber sehr breit.
Umgekehrter Rasen.
Keine Ahnung, wie beschreibt man das denn?
I have approximate knowledge of many things.
Das war jetzt eine Adventure Time Reference.
Hab ich mal von gehört.
Ja, also ich hatte mir, wie gesagt,
diesen Audio-Vortrag angehört, das hatte ich ja schon
erzählt, der hat irgendwie fünf
Regeln aufgestellt oder sechs, die
er empfehlen
wollte, die ich alle auf dieser Aufnahme noch
nicht ausprobiert habe.
Vielleicht kommt das bei der Nacharbeitung noch
zum Spiel, also dass du zum Beispiel
dein Gain
Was genau ist denn Gain?
Das ist quasi die Vorverstärkung
vom Signal, wenn ich jetzt hier
wenn ich jetzt an diesem Regler hier drehe
Ja, das sollte man
nicht zu weit aufdrehen.
Mal schauen, was
das Rechen auch vorne wieder komplett raus
Das kann ich hier machen, Regel 2
Sprache immer erstmal durch ein Low-Cut
beziehungsweise High-Pass-Filter
Warum heißt das
Low-Pass und High-Pass, warum heißt das Low-Cut?
Ja, das ist einfach plus
der gleiche Begriff andersrum
Low-Cut ist High-Pass
Das heißt einfach
hier alles unterhalb von
sollte man allgemein wegschneiden, weil da viel von
diesen Nebengeräuschen so
drin sind, die man eh nicht hören möchte.
Also geht es um Sprachrechtspeit?
Genau.
Also es ging hauptsächlich auch um Sprachaufnahmen.
Dann gab es
hier Q-Factor,
Filter, Sweep machen. Das ist, wenn du so
ich krieg's auch nicht mehr ganz zusammen,
aber du konntest mit dem Equalizer, dann
ist er irgendwie über das Signal gegangen mit einem Filter
einmal und hat gewisse Störfrequenzen gesucht.
Er hat dann irgendwie so ein Geräusch von seinem
Lüfter zu Hause aufgenommen und da waren
zwei Frequenzen drin.
Und hier ist er einmal drüber gegangen mit so einem
Equalizer-Sweep und hat gesucht,
ah, das Störgeräusch ist genau diese
Frequenz, da hat er ein möglichst schmales Band genommen
und das dann aus dem eigentlichen Signal
rausgeschnitten, um dieses eine
Rauschen wegzukriegen. Das waren zwei
Rauschen, die sich überlagert haben, zwei Frequenzen,
und die hat er dann beide einfach rausgenommen. Das klang sofort
ganz viel besser. Das erinnert mich an zwei Dinge.
Zum einen, dass dieser Typ, der mal so
durch so ein Zwischengerät,
dass er seinen Fernseher angeschlossen hat, bevor er seine Audioanlage geht,
wo er quasi auch Audiobearbeitung live am Fernsehsignal vornehmen konnte,
komplett die Wufuselas rausgeschnitten hatte, quasi aus Fußballspielen damals.
Also es klang halt wirklich exakt, wie das davor muss,
dass halt dieser gesamte nervige Grundton, der war, einfach fehlte.
Diese Afrika-WM.
Und das andere, dass Apple mal super stolz war,
als sie vor ein paar Jahren die Lüfter für die MacBooks erneuert hatten
und die ungleichmäßige Abstände zwischen den Fans hatten.
Achso, damit es nicht einschwingt.
Dass du halt nicht eine Frequenz hast,
die besonders laut ist, sondern diverse Frequenzen,
die dann aber dementsprechend leise sind.
Also die Quintessenz, die dabei rauskommen.
Mir ist natürlich was Witziges aufgefallen.
Bei meinem Arbeits-MacBook,
wenn ich da zwei, vier Kabel-Germer
anschließe, was ich grundsätzlich tue,
dann ist, je nachdem, was ich mache,
auch relativ schnell der Lüfter die ganze Zeit an.
Okay.
Weil Grafikkarte und sonst noch ein bisschen CPU,
die gehen sofort aus,
sobald du auf diesen Siri-Button drückst.
schön. Das Ding ist die ganze Zeit am Pusten
und dann drückst du auf diesen Siri-Button
und dann ist es wirklich
sofort aus.
Krass, aber schön, dass auf sowas geachtet wird, damit Siri
besser zuhören kann. Wir haben mal kurz hier
Lüfter ausgemacht.
Okay, krass. Faszinierend.
Na gut, okay, also ich war bei diesem komischen Sweep, also es gibt
irgendwie Techniken, die ich jetzt nicht ganz wiedergeben
kann, mit denen man so Störfrequenzen rausfiltern kann.
Das nächste war,
ein bisschen Kompressor kann man drüberlegen, damit...
Kurz zurück, du nutzt Siri auf dem MacBook?
Nein, ich habe aus irgendeinem Grund mal kurz auf diesen Knopf gedrückt.
Mir ist es, wie gesagt, neulich nach anderthalb Jahren, die ich dieses Gerät habe, überhaupt zum ersten Mal aufgefallen.
Okay.
Genau, also Kompressor-Gate soll man nie verwenden, nicht auf Sprachaufnahmen.
Gate ist, wenn du ab einer gewissen Lautstärke abschneidest.
dass das quasi so einengst und dann hast du sofort auch
so einen Übersteuerungseffekt.
Nicht gut. Und ja, zum Schluss
einfach nochmal normalisieren.
Die Lautstärke.
Normalisieren der Lautstärke.
Genau, dass du
die Momente, wo ich so rede,
und die Momente, wo ich so rede, einigermaßen
in so ein gleiches
Spektrum,
in den gleichen Bereich bringst.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig bei unserem Aufnahmeset,
weil ich leider diese Headsets gekauft habe,
so ein leichtes Grundrauschen haben.
Also vielleicht, wenn noch mal irgendwas aufkommt, sollten wir noch mal
ein bisschen bessere Headsets investieren.
Weil dieses, ich sag mal
nichts, aber geh mal mit dem Gain hoch bei dem hier.
Ja,
ich verstehe, was du meinst. Das ist ein Feature von dem
Headset. Das ist die Frage, wie viel man in dem
Podcast noch davon hören kann, nachdem
es auch vorne durchgegangen ist. Ein bisschen.
Also jetzt wurde es so laut gemacht. Und nachdem
ich mir jetzt diese fünf
Schritte, die man hier durchgehen kann,
angeschaut habe, habe ich mich auch gefragt.
Die Frage hat dort keiner laut gestellt, aber es waren definitiv ein paar Leute im Raum, die Podcasts machen.
Wie viel davon ist eigentlich einfach bloß das, was Auphonic macht?
Auphonic ist halt das Tool schlicht hin.
Also wenn ihr Auphonic noch nicht kennt und Podcasts aufnehmt, nutzt das.
Das ist so toll. Auphonic.com ist ein Webservice, aber so unglaublich praktisch für die Nachbearbeitung.
Ich mache nochmal den Test. Ich drehe nochmal dieses Rauschen auf.
Und dann können wir jetzt hinterher, wenn ihr diesen Podcast hört, werdet ihr sehen, ob dieses Rauschen noch da ist.
Es beginnt jetzt.
Es ist oben.
Ich höre mich selber auf deinem Video.
Sei froh, dass ich nichts gesagt habe, als ich das aufgedreht habe.
Gut, okay.
Ja, das war zumindest das.
Das fand ich sehr spannend.
Wie gesagt, unser Kumpel Sascha hat drei Vorträge gehalten.
Zwei über seine Arbeit und seine Firma, nämlich über Neo4j.
Ich wollte Spaß, dass ich aber kurz MongoDB reinwerfen würde,
dass ich mir nachher ein Beschwerden kann.
Arbeitet überhaupt jemand an MongoDB?
Und wenn ja, gibt der zu, dass er an MongoDB arbeitet.
Zwei darüber,
einen spannenderweise darüber,
dass mit Neo4j
offenbar diese Panama Papers
aufgearbeitet wurden.
Darüber würde ich Ihnen alleine sehr gerne mal einen Podcast holen.
Das sollten wir machen. Sascha, hast du Bock?
Ja, Sascha, wenn du das jetzt hier hörst,
ruf mich mal direkt an.
Genau und noch einen über
das Arbeiten als
oder das Leben als Remote
Entwickler, weil
er ja für eine Firma arbeitet, die überhaupt nicht in Dresden
sitzt, aber in Dresden arbeitet
und verbringt halt seinen Tag in einem
Coworking Space, zusammen
mit
witzigerweise gehen die immer zusammen mit Arressen,
zusammen mit Henrik, der hier bei
Mozilla arbeitet, der hier auch schon mal zu Gast war bei mir.
Ja genau und darüber
Da habe ich leider überhaupt keine Ahnung von.
Ich bin auch froh, dass ich meinen Arbeitsalltag
nicht so aussieht.
Aber Sascha, komm mal vorbei.
Finde ich cool.
Genau. Ich habe meinen
WebAssembly-Vortrag dort nochmal spontan gehalten.
Daraufhin
Der Wasim is Awesome.
Ich habe den ein bisschen eingekürzt, aber das hätte ich
gar nicht machen müssen, weil ich habe zum Beispiel diese ganzen
Performance-Folien einfach komplett rausgenommen.
Und dann hat hinterher doch nochmal jemand gefragt,
und wie ist das mit der Performance? Hast du da irgendwie Daten?
Ich habe gedacht, warte mal, ich habe diese Folie gerade gelöscht.
und als das dann jemand
vertwittert hatte, dass ich diesen Vortrag gehalten habe,
hat dann noch ein Kumpel geschrieben, ah, gibt's da
für eine Aufzeichnung?
Und ich so, nee,
aber ich könnte den ja vielleicht nochmal auf
einem Meetup halten, gibt's eigentlich diesen Webmontag
noch? Und da haben wir
ganz am Anfang ja kurz drüber geredet gehabt.
Die haben mich dann angeschrieben
mit, ja, den Webmontag gibt's noch oder
jetzt wieder.
Der nächste ist nächsten Montag und da bin ich dann gleich mal hingegangen.
Das ist hier in Drixen im Impact
gewesen. Das ist auch so ein
Coworking-Thing, oder? Das ist so ein Coworking-Space.
Das klingt eher so ein bisschen vom Namen her wie
so ein Incubator. Passt auf jeden Fall.
Ich war da, das ist so am Bahnhof.
Schicke Location.
Am Hauptbahnhof da? Genau. So ein bisschen,
wenn du hinten lang an den Bushaltestellen,
also an diesen Reisebushaltestellen lang
gehst. Ah, da ist das.
Okay. Ja, und das ist
ganz typisch. Also die haben so ein paar
und Kühlschränke mit ganz
viel Premium-Cola und
ganz viele verteilte kleine Schreibtische
und diese großen, geilen
Holz-Tafel-Tische, wo du
gemeinsam transzettelst. Das ist ein typischer
Coworking-Space, so wie du es auf
den
The Perfect Office-Bildern
immer siehst.
Sehr nice. Ja, und da gab es zwei Vorträge. Der eine war
von einem Typen, der eigentlich
glaube ich bloß der Marketing
und KI verbindet und der hat einfach
über KI allgemein geredet.
Das war ein bisschen sehr
allgemein gehalten. Zum Schluss hat er noch
ein paar Beispiele genannt, was Firmen damit machen.
Und der andere Vertrag war von einem Mitarbeiter von Cloud & Heat, die hier in Dresden mit Computern Wärme produzieren, absichtlich.
Das klingt zu absurd, aber das ist eine echt coole Idee.
Über Monitoring, also direkt über Prometheus und Grafana.
Sehr spannend eigentlich.
Obwohl wir das auf Arbeit auch selber benutzen, habe ich da nie so genau reingeguckt, was da passiert.
Ja, also ich kann dieses Meetup allgemein empfehlen. Allgemein finde ich, dass es in Dresden noch ein paar Meetups mehr geben könnte. Es gibt ja so ein paar Kandidaten, die von Meetup zu Meetup gehen und zu wirklich jedem gehen, aber es könnte wirklich gerade im Webspace, wie gesagt, dieser Webmontag ist von den Leuten organisiert, die gleichzeitig das Vue.js Meetup machen.
Da gab es das, wo wir das letzte Mal waren,
das Dresden.js-Meetup,
wo eigentlich nur Angular-Entwickler sind.
Aber es gibt auch noch ein extra Angular-Meetup in Dresden.
Das sind nämlich die Leute, die das Angular-Meetup machen.
Ich habe bis heute keine Ahnung, was Angular genau ist.
Muss ich mal ganz offen hier zugeben.
Also ich war immer unter der Annahme,
das ist einfach nur ein Frontend-Framework.
Ja.
Ach so.
Und warum sagen dann Leute,
dass sie als Programmierensprache nur Angular kennen?
Weil, ich weiß nicht warum.
Ich sehe mich selber ja auch als Fab-Entwickler, aber nicht als Frontend-Entwickler.
Dieses Auskristallisieren der unterschiedlichen Frameworks und Leute, die sich dann nur als React-Engineer oder als Angular-Engineer bezeichnen, kann ich als Sprache gut nachvollziehen.
Als Sprache ist glaube ich falsch.
Ich höre das bloß und deshalb war ich verwirrt, aber das ist wirklich Bullshit.
Das ist einfach JavaScript und HTML, Template-Sprache. Ja, es hat irgendwie so ein bisschen seinen eigenen Template-Dialekt.
aber es ist
Quatsch zu sagen, okay
dann verstehe ich was du meinst
aber es ist glaube ich mehr ein Framework
als es zum Beispiel React ist
weil React wirklich nur
Komponenten baut
und Angular
holistischer ist
gut, ich bestecke hier nicht in der vorhandenen
Entwicklung so drin, also so ganz und überhaupt
gar nicht, ich schäme mich ein bisschen, dass ich mich ein bisschen mehr damit auskenne
ich weiß nicht mehr was du mit Komponenten meinst
äh
ja
Wenn du deinen eigenen HTML-Tag baust.
Aha.
So was wie, also ein Tag, den du mit
Engelbrackets hinschreibst, mit Attributen
drinne. Da kannst du Sachen reingeben
und dann passieren Sachen, die mehr sind als nur
ein Standard-HTML-Tag.
Das ist eine Komponente.
Spannend. Ich weiß nichts
von Web mehr.
Gar nicht.
Ja genau, das ist diese
Spaltung in unserer Industrie,
dass sich die Leute, zum einen,
die einen kennen sich nur mit
Mobile aus
und die anderen nur mit Web. Das finde ich schade.
Aber wenn du...
Wahrscheinlich ist das sogar viel zu ähnlich beides
und das weiß bloß niemand. Wahrscheinlich könnten
wir auch sehr viel voneinander lernen und
tun es nicht.
Zum Beispiel sowas wie
React Native.
Wie ähnlich ist das zu
einer nativen iOS-Entwicklung?
Nicht ähnlich.
Genau.
Aber von der Sorte
noch im Mobile Camp einige Leute. Ich saß dann abends
mit Leuten am Tisch.
Ich habe irgendwie so Party in einer Kneipe gemacht. Warst du da mit
dabei? Nee, bei der Party war ich nicht so
nicht. Stimmt. Und dann
habe ich auch gesagt, ja, es gibt ja tatsächlich so
PHP-Vorträge oder
Eclipse irgendwie. Wir haben
jetzt so ein Tool auf der Arbeit mal benutzen müssen.
Das war in Eclipse gebaut.
Da habe ich mir direkt sofort die Frage gestellt.
Oh, seit wie vielen Jahren wird das wohl
nicht mehr maintained?
Ich wundere, wie viele Leute haben. Und der Typ neben mir
sagt so, also ich benutze, ich entwickle
Tag mit Eclipse.
Ich habe mir jetzt ein Haus gekauft.
Es funktioniert.
Man kann damit
Geld verdienen.
Unser Backend ist übrigens
in PHP aus guten Gründen.
Dieser, jener und welcher.
Krass.
Es ist spannend, wie
man doch in so Silos leben kann
und voneinander nichts mitbekommt.
Ja,
es ist faszinierend. Es gibt wirklich
PHP und Slash Eclipse entwickelt, also gar nicht.
Dieser,
wir müssen es in PHP schreiben,
einer der Hauptgründe, der mir da genannt wurde,
war, Hosting ist einfach extrem viel billiger.
Weil es immer noch diese Lampstack...
Du hostest doch auf keinem
hier sonst wieder hergelaufenem C-Panel,
Lampstack ist schon vorinstalliert, Hoster und
Managed Server, wer macht das?
Das machen Firmen,
die sich mal eben
was zusammenbauen lassen, so irgendwie
deine lokale Dachdeckerfirma oder
sowas. Okay, stimmt auch.
Und die haben dann da Hosting-Kosten
von drei Euro im Monat für sowas.
Das ist ein Argument, nicht jeder ist halt wirklich eine Software-Klitsche.
Genau. Und du könntest dir
jetzt natürlich irgendwie einen Software-Entwickler
anheuern, der dir was baut und
dir dann irgendwo einen V-Host
oder irgendwo ein Docker-Image oder sowas
hinlegt, wo eine ganze Anwendung
in einem Kubernetes-Cluster
gehostet ist.
Aber dann im Endeffekt hast du vielleicht
eine Anwendung, auf der du dreimal
am Tag rumklickst, um irgendwelche Kundendaten einzugeben
oder irgendwelche Pläne zu geben.
Die meisten wollen wirklich einfach nur ein einfaches CMS, wenn überhaupt.
Oder die Webseite ist einfach statisch und
20 Jahre nicht angefasst. Genau, wenn deine
Webseite nicht dein Produkt ist,
sondern dein Werkzeug,
dann hast du ein bisschen andere Anforderungen.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Das stimmt wirklich.
Und solche Leute sagen sich dann auch,
ja, ich habe hier dieses Windows
ThinkPad.
Muss ich das auf einer Webseite machen?
Kann man da nicht eine Desktop-Anwendung bauen?
Und zack, kriegst du so eine
Eclipse-Anwendungen zusammengerührt.
Die im Endeffekt...
Eclipse-Anwendungen?
Ja.
Es gibt so ein Eclipse-UI-Toolkit oder was?
Na, Eclipse selber ist mit dem Eclipse-UI-Toolkit gebaut.
Es gibt ein Eclipse-UI?
Ja.
Du siehst Anwendungen, du erkennst richtig,
die Tabs sehen dort anders aus.
Die Tabs sehen aus wie in der Eclipse,
wie in der IDE.
Fancy Shit, was es nicht alles gibt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und das stürzt auf die seltsamsten Orten und Weisen ab.
Aber die Leute bauen sich dann was zusammen,
und das macht im Hintergrund dann auch bloß Rest-Calls
an irgendeine PHP-Anwendung.
Aber es ist halt
lokal.
Ja, finde ich immer noch besser als eine Electron.
Das habe ich ein bisschen schockiert gehabt, als der eine Typ
in der Mobile Camp Keynote da
die
naja, war
Welche Keynote war das?
Die Keynote am Samstag früh.
Das war auch so ein IBM-Typ,
der auch
Bilderkennung gemacht hat und
hier das als cooles Feature verkauft hat,
dass die IBM Cloud ja hier
Anbindung an SAP-Systeme hat mit
Bilderkennung und du schaust dir halt an,
wie er durch irgendwelche SAP-Interfaces durchgeklickt hat
und so, wow, das sieht ja
toll aus, das ist ja
wunderschön und damit kann man
jetzt hier in der Industrie
Kameras betreiben, die
erkennen, ob in dem Kanister ein Teil drin liegt.
Ja, okay, Bilderkennung ist jetzt
also ich meine...
mit Elektronen zu tun?
Nichts. Achso.
Ich kann bloß drauf über die wunderschöne
SAP-Benutzerführung
da, so ein Interface, wo du quasi
gleichzeitig das Interface
mit bearbeiten kannst
und einfach mal ein neues
Dropdown daneben ziehst.
Wenn du dir eine Anwendung baust, die einfach bloß mal
ab und zu etwas auf der Festplatte
speichert und danach das dann irgendwann
über einen REST-Interface mit einem Web-Service
synchronisiert, dann kannst du das doch auch
in Elektron bauen. Ja, es ist dann halt eine ziemlich
großer Container, das stimmt.
Ich sehe absolut keinen Grund dafür,
jemals irgendwas, auch nur kleines, ein Elektron zu bauen.
Da gibt es,
mach es doch lieber gleich mit Qt oder so.
Es läuft tausendmal besser, auch wenn es hässlich ist.
Ja, aber
der Hauptgrund dafür ist,
dass du dann komplett
neue Technologie-Stack lernen musst.
Wenn du schon Web-Entwickler bist,
dann sehe ich den Ansatz.
Aber nicht jeder ist schon Web-Entwickler.
Und nicht nur Web-Entwickler wollen Software für
Desktop schreiben.
Wahrscheinlich müsste man das
ich nehme mir seit Jahren
vor, mal irgendwie eine Desktop-Anwendung
mit Qt zu bauen. Ich habe es nie so
richtig gemacht.
Vor allem, weil diese Beispiele auf der Qt-Seite
mich so ein bisschen abgeschreckt haben, wo dann Logik
in der Klasse drin ist,
die einfach bloß so ein Dialog
irgendwo hinmalt. Das sind schon keine Best Practices,
das sind im Beispiel Code drin.
Da fängst du dann wieder an, auch so eine Server
Client UI,
das sind jetzt die Begriffe, wo die Leute
aus dem HelloSwift-Podcast mir wahrscheinlich
auf die Finger hauen würde, wo du einfach diese saubere Trennung
hinkriegen möchtest, dass du eigentlich eine
Library bauen möchtest, also ich
eine Library bauen würdest, die deine Anwendungslogik
beinhaltet,
die einen Haufen Function-Calls anbietet,
die dann von einer komplett separierten
Anwendung... Also generell willst du
das Zeug ja trennen, du willst deine Logik nicht
in deinem View-Krams drin haben.
Das ist schon richtig. Wenn ich dann in diese
Beispiele reingucke, denke ich mir das mal,
macht man das bei
macht man das bei Qt so?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das die Best Practices sind,
aber es machen Leute so. Genauso wie Leute
halt gegen alle Best Practices immer verstoßen,
überall. Einfach nur, weil man es
halt anders machen kann.
Aber gerade so die PyQt-Sachen,
die finde ich, das macht großartig Spaß,
da wird man ein bisschen rumzubasteln.
PyQt? Also generell die Python-Binding-Für-Cutie.
Achso, du meinst Qt-Anwendungen
bauen mit Python? Genau.
Finde ich toll. Macht mega viel Spaß.
Ja, stimmt. Das habe ich tatsächlich schon gemacht.
Ach wunderbar, da hast du ja schon eine Qt-Anwendung.
Stimmt, ich hab das nie so als
wahre Qt-Anwendung
Das ist voll eine wahre Qt-Anwendung
Ja, wenn du sowas machst
ich nenne jetzt niemanden bei Namen, aber ich kenne Leute, die bei Firmen
arbeiten, die Produkte verkaufen
die komplett in Python geschrieben sind und mit Qt
und da läufst du dann wieder in andere
Probleme rein
Denn so eine umfangreiche Python-Anwendung
die musst du erstmal ausgeliefert kriegen
das sind dann einfach
ein paar hundert Megabyte Python-Source-Code, den du mit ausliefern musst
das wird dann irgendwie komisch auch
gebundelt in irgendein
Executable, wo dann der ganze Source-Code mit drin
liegt. Das finde ich ja schon wieder komisch.
Wenn jemand mir sagt, bau doch eine Anwendung
mit Qt für den
Desktop, dann denke ich an C++,
weil da fällt ein Binary raus, was
zum Schluss deine Anwendung ist.
Ja, krass. Trotzdem, es gibt Bindings
für alles. Aber stimmt.
PyQt und PyGtK
komplett in JavaScript bleiben
und trotzdem eine Qtio einrühren.
Gibt es das QtNote?
Ich würde mich fast wundern, wenn nicht, aber ich
glaube ich selber noch nicht gesehen.
Aber ich muss gestehen, das, was du sagst, ich finde es auch ein bisschen
erschreckend, wenn man manchmal so Software bedient und dann merkt,
dass es etwas Größeres, Komplexes ist,
komplett in Python geschrieben.
Ich mag Python sehr gern,
aber bei größeren Projekten denke ich mir, da muss es doch
unrunde Ecken geben. Irgendwo muss es auch unerwartet
irgendwie einfach nur abkratzen.
Du musst dich ja bloß fünf Minuten mit den Entwicklern
unterhalten.
Und das ist bei all diesen Anwendungen so.
Also Python ist
schön, solange du nicht mehr als tausend Zeilen
Code schreibst.
Naja, gut, okay. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder in dem Meinungsbereich
und den Sachen,
über die wir eh die ganze Zeit reden.
Was haben wir
denn sonst noch so an unseren Notizen?
Die Vorträge vom
Mobilcamp, die jetzt erwähnenswert waren,
sind wir einigermaßen durch. Es gab noch einen
über Progressive Web Apps.
Da muss ich aber auch sagen, da ist mir aufgefallen, aha, es ist
ein Barcamp, denn da ist offenbar jemand
an dem Tag hingegangen, spontan hat gesagt, ah, ist ja
ein Barcamp. Ich melde mal selber was an.
Obwohl er überhaupt nicht, also so habe ich es gemacht, aber ich hatte
wenigstens den Vortrag schon zweimal gehalten.
wenigsten finde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Es ist schön, wenn man was dabei hat, aber
gerade das macht Sparkab ja auch aus, wenn man mal
so Diskussionsvorträge hat, wo man sagt, okay, lass uns doch
über PWA sprechen. Genau, da hatte jemand einen PWA-Vortrag
oder einen PWA-Slot
angemeldet
und da sind alle hingegangen
und du gehst dann immer mit dem Hintergedanken
jetzt lerne ich mal, was über PWA sind.
Und die,
das war vornehmlich so, ja,
PWA, es gibt's, man schreibt so ein Manifest,
hier, ich scrolle mal komplett durch so ein Manifest durch,
ihr habt jetzt überhaupt nichts gesehen.
Ich habe auch nicht erwähnt, wo man sich reinlesen kann mit,
wie fängt man denn überhaupt an oder was sind so.
Es gibt halt PWAs.
Ja, wir machen das.
Okay, idealerweise sollte man eine gewisse Intro mitbringen,
das stimmt.
Um die Leute abzuholen, die keine Ahnung haben,
wo die im Leben sind.
Ich bin dahinter herausgegangen und habe mir gedacht,
ja, es gibt also PWAs, wusste ich schon.
Die machen das, das weiß ich jetzt, dass die das machen.
Aber schlau bin ich jetzt nicht.
War ein bisschen schade.
cool fand ich noch eine andere Session
das war von dem Typen, der
in Star Trek T-Shirts rumgerannt ist
der über
wo bleibt eigentlich der geile Scheiß
sprechen wollte, der hier
in Science Fiction, Star Trek, The Expanse
er wollte explizit sagen
dass er kein Star Wars Fan ist, weil Star Wars kein
Sci-Fi ist, sondern ein Space Opera
gut, ist ja richtig
meinetwegen, spielt ja einer long, long time ago
stimmt, stimmt
also wie zu viel wandert mit der Storyout
Star Wars Charaktere sind alle schon tot.
Vielleicht sind wir die nachkommen.
Das fand ich ein bisschen kritisch, aber red ruhig weiter.
Ich fand den Talk cool, weil generell mal so
hier, das sind so coole
Communicator oder generell coole
Interfaces, die es in der Expanse Welt
gibt oder so. Warum haben wir sowas noch nicht?
Was hindert uns daran, sowas cooles zu bauen?
Ich fände den Ansatz cool,
generell mal über sowas zu quatschen, auch wenn
das dann meiner Meinung nach
ein bisschen, also es ging
sehr viel um Regularien und warum
um die EU ein scheiß Umfeld ist,
um Startups zu gründen, das war ein bisschen weird.
Aber worüber sich ja meiner Meinung nach
auch niemand Gedanken gemacht hat, ist,
ja, ich meine, so generell Display Richtung
Wand halten, also Handy Richtung
Fernseher halten und mit dem Finger
übers Handy swipen, um quasi Content da auf die Wand
zu schieben, ist eine coole Idee.
Das kann man gerne
versuchen umzusetzen, da gibt es auch andere.
Ich glaube, Samsung hat tatsächlich sogar sowas ähnliches mit drin.
Aber was halt so fehlt
immer in so Sci-Fi, ist halt jegliche Form
von Sicherheit,
Identifizierung oder generell
Edge-Cases, sondern es ist halt bloß immer,
hier im Best-Case könnte das so funktionieren.
Ja gut, darüber muss man nicht nachdenken.
Das ist eine Show oder
ein Buch oder was auch immer. Das spielt keine
Rolle da, aber das kannst du doch einfach
nicht so. Bei The Expanse
wird das relativ detailliert beschrieben.
Zumindest in den Büchern.
Also nochmal, der Vortrag ging darum,
guck mal, in diesen ganzen Sci-Fi-Filmen gibt es
coole Technologie, was müssen wir machen,
um diese Technologie endlich
zu bekommen? Ich möchte das auch haben.
Was völlig am Ziel, am Thema
vorbeiging, finde ich,
ist, dass zum Beispiel The Expanse, wenn du es dir genau
anguckst, eigentlich keine
Utopie ist, sondern es ist eher
eine Dystopie.
Quatsch. Weißt du, Krieg zwischen Erde und Mars
und den Beltern? Ja, und die Leute leben
total unterdrückt in diesen
Gürtler.
Klingt ja fantastisch.
Stimmt, der deutsche Begriff ist ja schrecklich.
In diesen Raumstationen und
diese Technologie, mit dem ich swipe
mal eben was von meinem
Glass-Smartphone-Terminal
an die Wand, funktioniert halt,
weil das Smartphone kein eigener Computer
ist. Das ist halt ein Client
auf dem Netzwerk. Es ist halt ein großer
Computer. Es ist halt ein Netzwerk.
Die Computer ist die Burg.
Die Cloud ist die Burg.
Aber ich meine, in der selben Serie wird
halt auch beschrieben, dass es halt ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
auf der Erde gibt, weil nämlich die Erde
allgemein
mit 20 Milliarden Menschen überbevölkert
ist und es überhaupt keine Arbeit für überhaupt
irgendwen noch gibt. Das heißt, du musst
irgendwie eine Lotterie gewinnen, um studieren
oder auf die Schule gehen zu dürfen.
Du musst irgendwie
dort dann möglichst gut sein, um
einen Arbeitsplatz zu kriegen. Ansonsten lebst du
den Rest deines Lebens von Basic. Also es kriegt
quasi einfach jeder Arbeitslosengeld.
Und das ist eigentlich
keine Utopie.
Nee, das wäre aber auch eine scheiß Story, wenn es einfach eine reine
Utopie ist. Also niemand schaut die Serie Friede vor
der Eierkuchen. Und die
Serie fängt an damit,
so einem Timelapse, wie die
Pole schmelzen und wie der
Meeresspiegel steigt.
Die Leute verlassen
die Erde Richtung Mars, weil sie
die Erde verlassen müssen quasi.
Es gibt halt diese unterdrückte
Minderheit, die
im Asteroidengürtel
lebt.
Ist durchaus spannend.
Es ist auch
wunderschön realistisch, aber halt
nicht unbedingt erstrebenswert.
Was ich dann irgendwie laut sagen wollte, ist,
dieser geile neue Scheiß, den wir machen,
oder sowas, das ist halt genau, geht
für mich, witzig, dass ich das als
Technologist
sage,
völlig in die falsche Richtung. Eigentlich müsste sich die Menschheit
ein bisschen zurücknehmen. Mal
jetzt, ich finde, wir sollten einfach
eingestehen, dass wir vielleicht den Peak-Technology erreicht
haben und
einfach ein bisschen wieder runterfahren
müssen, denn, ich meine, es gehen
freitags die ganzen Schüler auf die Straße
und demonstrieren gegen Klimawandel.
Warum gibt es überhaupt einen Klimawandel?
Weil wir hier sitzen mit unseren Laptops, die irgendwie Strom verbrauchen.
Wir sind noch nicht Diesel betrieben.
Lass uns doch mit mehr Technologie das Problem lösen.
Lass uns doch mit mehr Technologie Autos abschaffen.
Also das Problem ist einfach unser Energieverbrauch.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Den haben wir schön hochgefahren, aber den können wir doch auch senken
und gleichzeitig nicht Technologie eindämmen.
Hoffentlich, ja.
Also ich meine, das momentane Problem ist, dass wir ja Zeugs verbrennen,
was Milliarden Jahre lang oder Millionen Jahre lang im Boden gespeichert war und nie wieder in den Boden zurückkehren wird.
Und das wird dauerhaft in der Atmosphäre bleiben.
Aber selbst wenn wir Energie auf erneuerbare Art und Weise gewinnen, werden wir trotzdem in Prozessen immer Wärme produzieren,
die irgendwo hin muss und die dann auch in der Atmosphäre bleiben.
Ja, also das ist ganz ohne Energie, die sonst wohin abgeführt wird in anderer Form, nicht funktioniert.
das glaube ich auch.
Dennoch
träume ich von einer
Sci-Fi-Zukunft, grün
und silber und glasig.
Wo alles wunderschön zusammenpasst.
Ich habe ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung,
dass sich die Menschen irgendwie
auch ihren Platz,
ihrer Platzgier, ihrer Raum hier
ein bisschen hinter sich lassen, dass ich immer
schlimm finde, sind diese Dörfer
in Deutschland überall, nichts gegen Dörfer
oder Leute, die auf Dörfern leben.
Aber es ist ganz schön platzhungrig, dass irgendwie
fünf Leute in so einem Ort
wohnen, der
außerhalb der Stadt ist,
wo alles hingefahren werden muss,
wo sie jeden Tag mit dem Auto
dann wegfahren müssen, um...
Ich würde behaupten, die gängige Meinung ist, Städte zu
haten, weil die so gigantisch sind, aber
du reitest hier auf den ekligen
Dörfern rum, die viel zu groß
für die Menge von Menschen sind und dass sie
sich nicht einfach in der Stadt untergliedern.
Wenn die Menschen konzentrieren würde,
das in Städte,
Und den Rest verwalten lässt.
Dann, ja,
welchen Raum passenden,
wenn du dir quasi als Vorbild
eine Großstadt nimmst, meinetwegen,
nimm eine amerikanische Großstadt,
nimm beispielsweise New York City.
Wenn du alle Menschen auf die Dichte wie New York City
zusammenpackst, was für eine Fläche würden wir dann
einnehmen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Aber ich meine,
du kennst diese Infografik, wo du eine
vierspurige, achtspurige Straße
hast, wo voll mit
Autos, wo jeweils einer drin sitzt und dann gibt es diese
Grafikus die gleichen Leute auf Fahrräder und Busse
und Straßenbahn verteilen.
Genau, zwei Busse und drei Fahrräder.
Das überlege ich mir halt.
Ich wohne auf einem Dorf, ich habe ein Haus mit einem Garten.
Das ist wunderschön, aber ich
verbrauche damit sehr viel Raum, der auch
der Natur zurückgegeben
werden könnte.
Ja, was würden die blöde Natur damit anfangen?
Die macht eine Wiese hin, da ist auch nichts.
Die laufen dann Reh rum.
Die können auch hinter dem Haus lang rauf.
Ja, also zumindest dieses Mehr-Technologie ist nicht unbedingt so das Utopische.
Es ist schon sinnvoll, darüber nachzudenken und irgendwo einen coolen Mittelweg zu finden.
Aber ich bin nicht der Meinung, wir sollten jetzt aufhören, irgendwie technologischen Fortschritt.
Das nicht, das nicht, aber dieses Mehr-Mehr-Mehr ist halt...
Nee, also das Wachstum generell schädlich ist, da gehe ich dir gerne mit.
Da habe ich sogar gar nicht mal einen Talk drüber gehalten.
Bei irgendwas. Achso, in der Piraten-Parteizentrale vor ein paar Jahren.
dass das Wachstum nicht das große Ziel sein sollte,
generell, weil es immer nur geht um Wachstum, Wachstum, Wachstum, Wachstum.
Unternehmen, Nationen, alles muss wachsen.
Das ist ganz schrecklich.
Was ich gerade noch sagen wollte,
achso, bloß eine leichte Zahngelde noch dazu finden,
gerade wenn du schon meinst, so Umweltverpestungen
und was wir so machen, was so die nächsten Jahrhunderte,
wenn nicht sogar länger noch da rumbleibt.
Ich habe noch eine Serienempfehlung,
ich weiß nicht, ob du es schon gesehen hast.
Es ist eine neue HBO-Miniseries,
sprich es gibt nur fünf Folgen.
vier gibt es aktuell, die fünfte kommt noch nächste Woche.
Die Serie Tschernobyl
ist richtig, richtig, richtig
gut. Also erstaunlich gut.
Fängt an mit der Explosion
in, können erraten,
welche Explosion.
83, 86, 83 war es glaube ich.
Fängt an in dem
Moment quasi und geht
dann halt Schritt für Schritt
erstmal die Sekunden
danach, die Minuten danach, Tage, Wochen, Monate
später, was die halt gemacht haben und was sie halt auch
verkackt haben dort vor Ort. Ist
Faszinierend und auch super interessant.
Genau, kann ich wärmstens empfehlen.
Schaut die mal an, schaut ihr euch die an, ihr lieben Hörer.
Ist echt zu empfehlen.
Ich meine, man weiß natürlich ganz grob, was da passiert ist.
Im Sinne von, es gab eine Explosion, es ist irgendwie Strahlung ausgetreten.
Dann gab es viele Winde Richtung Westen.
Diese Strahlungswolke ist schön nach Europa rübergetragen worden.
Oder beziehungsweise nach Osteuropa da.
Hat sich richtig viel übertragen aus der Osterkraine.
Europa auch.
Ich meine aber vor allem halt erstmal über Osteuropa und generell da noch Russland, Ukraine und so weiter.
Und heutzutage ist da ein Betonsarg drüber.
Das waren die Details, die ich vorher so wusste.
Und mit der Serie weißt du halt wirklich, was da passiert ist.
Und vor allem auch so ein bisschen politisch drumherum.
Ich meine, Sowjetrussia damals ist halt so eine Nation, die nichts eingestehen kann.
Die halt keine Schwäche gegenüber der Welt zugeben kann.
Und dann gibt es da so eine Szene, in der...
Also ich will jetzt nicht spoilern.
Lass es mal erzählen.
ich kann es nur raten, die selber anzuschauen.
Du kriegst an vielen Stellen mit, wie die halt umgehen.
Gerade damit, also erst wollen sie es geheim halten,
später kriegst du halt das Ausland auch mit
und sprichst es an und dann können sie es halt nicht mehr geheim halten.
Aber dann geben sie halt nur gewisse Details raus
und nie so wirklich, was alles passiert ist
und wie schlimm es wirklich ist.
Dass eine Explosion, dass da ein Atomreaktor explodiert ist,
haben die Leute, glaube ich, immer nur raten können in den anderen Ländern.
Da gibt es so eine Szene, ich glaube in der ersten Folge schon von,
jetzt ist, ich meine,
achso, ein nukleares Institut irgendwo war das,
ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwann eine Uni eingegliedert ist
oder nicht, und die haben halt gemessen, oh, da draußen
sind gerade irgendwie so 8 Milliröntgen in der Luft,
haben ein Fenster aufgemacht, plötzlich geht da so ein
Dosimeter los, und das ist komisch,
was ist da denn passiert?
Fährt er wieder zu und das Ding zurückgesetzt,
ah, es kommt von draußen, 8 Milliröntgen,
das muss ja das, das ist
ein nuklearer Hacker hier um die Ecke sein, rufen da an,
die völlig empört, das sind wir nicht, ja, was ist denn
sonst die Umgebung? Ja, Tschernobyl kann
nicht sein, die sind 400 Kilometer entfernt, wenn
die Strahlung von denen abbekommen, dann müsste
der Dekor komplett offen liegen.
Rufen wir da mal an.
Oder geht keiner ran.
Oho.
Krass fände ich die Geschichten.
Ich habe ein paar Togos drüber gesehen,
aber gerade diese
Strahlungsauswirkungen,
diese direkten Strahlungsauswirkungen
auf den menschlichen Körper sind halt extrem
erschreckend, wenn du darüber nachdenkst.
Die Leute, die dort als Liquidatoren
reingegangen sind, um da irgendwie den Schutt
vom Dach wegzukehren,
sie sind halt alle innerhalb von wenigen Tagen oder Wochen
darauf gestorben.
Ein Film, den ich mir irgendwann mal angeguckt habe
und ich habe es irgendwie hinterher bereut, war
U
571,
ich weiß nicht mehr, aber es war ein U-Boot-Film.
Das war nicht
Jagd auf Roter Oktober, sondern
russisches Atom-U-Boot
und die haben auch irgendwie einen Reaktorschaden
und dann müssen
die U-Boot-Besatzung
in den Reaktorraum und da irgendwelche Ventile
auf- oder zudrehen.
Und denen sagen sie, ja, hier zieh diesen Anzug an, dann bist du ein bisschen geschützt.
Das war aber irgendwie ein Gasschutzanzug mit einfach einer Gasmaske aus Gummi, der überhaupt nichts gebracht hat.
Und dass dieser komplett kaputt gegangen ist, ist extrem erschreckend.
Lässt sich auch echt halt nicht wirklich einschätzen, was so Strahlung mit dir macht.
Das sieht man auch in der Serie.
Da ist so eine Frau, die halt der Meinung ist, ihr Mann hat Verbrennung.
Ja, der hat Verbrennung, aber du kannst jetzt trotzdem nicht den anfassen.
Das ist halt was, was du als Mensch nicht wirklich schon...
ziemlich einfach. Also der Typ schrallt halt.
Achso. Also wenn du da reingehst,
du kriegst halt denselben Scheiß ab.
Du hast auch die Verbrennung halt
in jeder Zelle deines Körpers.
Nicht einfach bloß außen. Genau.
Also es ist nicht so die typischen, also
nicht sowas, was du als Mensch halt, ja da ist Feuer,
du greifst rein, ich sehe was passiert,
sondern da ist was quasi Unsichtbares in der Luft,
was dich komplett beeinflussen kann.
Und auch wenn du es jetzt nicht wirklich, also
ganz am Anfang der Serie greift so ein Feuerwehrmann
so einen Grafitblock nimmt, der in die Hand
und lässt den halt dann kurz darauf fallen,
nimmt den Handschuh, aber seine Hand ist halt komplett verbrannt.
Also komplett wie quasi
als ob er ein Lagerfeuer reingehalten hätte.
Ich meine, bei
ausreichender Strahlung passiert sowas halt, aber wenn du
halt nur eine geringere
Dosis, die immer noch sehr hoch ist, abbekommst,
dann hast du halt überhaupt keine Auswirkungen
und hast halt zwei Wochen später irgendwie
die ersten Krebs schon in dir drin. Oder halt
Jahre später. Das ist richtig krass.
Also du hast
kein Gefühl dafür als Mensch,
was so Strahlung
mit dir macht oder wie sie sich auswirken kann.
Eine Geschichte, die ich nur noch so am Rande
mitbekommen habe, ich habe es nie
wirklich bestätigt bekommen, aber meine Mutter hat auch immer erzählt,
ja, ich habe mir von der Schule mal so eine
Reise
nach Chernobyl gewonnen.
Das muss so, das war nicht,
Chernobyl war ja 86 und
das muss irgendwie so ein, zwei
Jahre vorher gewesen sein.
Und sie hat das aber glücklicherweise abgelehnt,
weil sie wollte
ja noch Kinder haben.
Da bin ich, muss ich sagen, rückblickend sehr langbar.
Aber sie wäre vor dem Unfall da gewesen?
Ich glaube, ja.
Warte, wäre es doch nicht so schlimm.
Es hat ein funktionierendes Atomkraftwerk gewesen.
Es hätte auch...
Also mit sehr schlechten Timing...
Du machst einen Schulausflug zu einem Atomkraftwerk und es explodiert.
Das erinnert mich an so eine...
Ich glaube, MDR oder WDR-Doku war das, die sie filmen wollten.
In einem dieser beiden norddeutschen Atomkraftwerke.
Ich glaube, es sind zwei.
Aber auf jeden Fall waren die in dem einen drin.
Und haben da halt mit den Leuten geredet.
Und plötzlich ging halt so ein Alarm.
Licht geht aus, rot wieder an
und plötzlich so richtig krass, aber
es ging halt so ein Alarmgeräusch an und so eine Lämpchen
blinkte und niemand dort hatte
eine Ahnung, was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Und dann haben die so ein 600-seitiges Manual ausgepackt,
haben da angefangen zu blättern und versucht
herauszufinden, was dieser Alarm eigentlich bedeutet
und eine Viertelstunde später ging der einfach aus.
Und was haben die dann gemacht? Sie haben sich gefreut,
dass das wieder aufgehört hat, haben das Manual
wieder weggepackt und dann am Ende
der Dreharbeiten sind sie wieder angegangen und nach
zwei Stunden ist das Kamerateam halt gegangen und sie haben bis dahin noch
keine Ahnung gehabt, was das eigentlich ist.
Wenn die halt...
Das ist ja unbedenklich.
Ja, eben. Ich will den Leuten jetzt nicht vorwerfen, die da arbeiten.
Aber wenn da solche Stümper arbeiten,
die keine Ahnung davon haben...
Wie viele Leute sind eigentlich schon durch Arbeiten an Windkraftanlagen
gestorben? Viele bestimmt.
Das ist ja ganz gefährlich, hochgradig gefährlich.
Die fallen da runter und während sie runterfallen,
lesen sie eine 600-seitige
Broschüre darüber, wie sie
darauf hätten achten sollen, dass sie nicht von einer Windkraftanlage runterfallen.
Die Dinge erzeugen ja Wind, also muss ja
vorsichtig sein. Wir wären nicht in so einer
windigen Zeit leben, wenn die nicht so Windkraft
wieder halten. Oder hast du schon mal
irgendwie Wind gespürt, ohne dass du so ein Ding sich drehen hast
sehen?
Ich bin mal auf der Autobahn an so einem
Windfeld vorbeigefahren
und das muss aber gerade irgendwie
in so einer
Wartungsphase gewesen sein.
Da waren 15, 20 solche
Windkraftanlagen, die
komplett still standen. Und
das ist ein komisches Bild. Das ist so ein bisschen
als ob so die Zeit stehen bleibt.
Das ist als ob du so lauter Uhren hast,
gar kein Wind oder was.
Es muss ja kein Wartungszustand sein.
Die kannst du einfach...
Ich habe noch nie gesehen, dass sie sich gar nicht drehen.
Wenn gerade nichts bläst, dann muss
da auch nichts sich drehen.
So ein bisschen drehen tun sie sich immer.
Anyway.
Okay.
Vielleicht hält man die ja in Bewegung, damit da nichts
festeint.
Zumindest Atomkraftwerke
sind schlecht.
Ich finde es ja geil, wenn Leute wirklich so
Gegner von Windkraft sind, weil
die ja die Landschaft verschandeln
oder wirklich so AfD-Politiker, die behaupten, die erzeugen Wind.
Also komm schon, wie naiv muss man in der Mitte sein?
Ich war ja letztes Jahr in Kalifornien.
Und in Deutschland gibt es irgendwie eine Gruppe von Leuten,
die haben in Norddeutschland so einen Verein gegründet
oder eine Partei sogar, ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Und die demonstrieren dagegen, dass du bei günstigen Lichtverhältnissen
am Horizont Windkraftanlagen im Wasser sehen kannst.
Wenn du am Strand stehst...
Und du siehst halt,
das zerstört den Horizont,
weil du siehst da hinten
eventuell wirklich ganz am Ende
so Daumennagel hoch.
Nee, also hier das Weiße vom Daumennagel hoch.
Vielleicht noch so eine Windkraftanlage,
wenn die Luft klar ist.
Das gibt es in Deutschland.
In Central Barbara,
was so eine
eigentlich so eine
Schickimicki-Stadt ist.
Viel prominentere Strandpromenade.
Da stehst du am Strand, da siehst du
1, 2, 3, 4
Bohrinseln, direkt
irgendwie so vielleicht einen Kilometer vom
Wasser weg, äh, vom Strand weg.
Und wenn du da ein bisschen
einen Highway lang die Küste hochfährst,
siehst du, das hört nicht auf.
Da sind einfach Bohrinsel hinter Bohrinsel,
hinter Bohrinsel, hinter Bohrinsel.
Du musst aufpassen, ich hatte mir da
gerade diese neuen Schuhe gekauft mit weißen Sohlen.
Wenn du am Strand langläufst, dass du in kein
Teer reintrittst. Aber der
ist komplett natürlich.
und
in Deutschland
gehen Leute demonstrieren
gegen Windkraftanlagen, die du
irgendwo am Horizont siehst.
Ist das nicht ein schönes Bild, wenn man da was am Horizont sehen kann?
Vor allem ist es nicht viel cooler, wenn du gerade so an der
letzten Horizontkante noch was siehst, weil du dann wirklich so
mal ein Gefühl für die Distanz hast.
Weißt du, wie weit du ihn sehen kannst auf flacher Ebene?
Also 5-6 Kilometer. Genau, 5 Kilometer siehst du.
Wenn du da gerade was an dem hintersten Eck noch sehen kannst,
wenn du da so ein bisschen über den Horizont weiter
hervorstehst, dann ist das halt etwas, was du nur
soweit kannst du eigentlich gar nicht blicken.
Vielleicht was für Flat Earther, vielleicht stören die sich daran.
Weil die daran sehen, dass die Erde...
Dass das hinter dem Horizont
verschwindet, das Zeug, das ist ja
the law of perspective.
Wie erklärt das
so ein Flat Earther?
Keine Ahnung. Ich bin mal irgendwann
nachts mit dem Tablet
ein YouTube-Video über
Flat Earth
Leute eingeschlafen und
dank Autoplay hatte ich dann
den nächsten Tag mal
Du bist jetzt voll in der Blase.
Da gibt es übrigens einen wunderschönen Dokumentar von Netflix.
Der ist geil. Behind the Curve.
Der Behind the Curve ist echt gut. Super cool.
Auch schön ist diese Aussage,
um nochmal auf Windkraftanlagen zurückzukommen,
die verschandeln in die Landschaft, wenn die irgendwo
auf dem Feld rumstehen.
Du denkst dir so, ja stimmt, stell dir mal vor,
du könntest jetzt über diese Landschaft gucken, da werden keine
Windkraftanlagen. Vielleicht, ja.
Aber irgendwann ist mir mal aufgefallen,
Was man so in einem Braunkohletage braucht?
Das sieht so schlimm aus.
Da werden irgendwie
hunderte, tausende Quadratkilometer
Landschaft weggebaggert, wo dann hinterher
nur noch Mondlandschaft übrig bleibt, mitten
in Deutschland. Da werden ganz Dörfer
abgebaggert. Da war vorher ein Dorf und das ist einfach
weg. Das ist einfach ein riesiges Loch.
Vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut, weil die Dörfer
die Leute sollten eh in die Stadt ziehen.
Das kann da ein See entstehen, wo sich Fische
ansiedeln.
Anyway, ja, verschandeln die Landschaft.
Ja, also ich finde,
Gerade so Windkrafträder in der Landschaft sehen halt auch super cool aus.
Das ist eine Gewöhnungssache.
Also wenn du nicht mit Windkraftanlagen in deiner Jugend aufgewachsen bist,
so wie unsere Eltern zum Beispiel.
Für mich war Windkraftanlage früher, ich kannte die nur aus Ostsee-Urlaub.
Ja genau, also wenn man zum Noten gefahren ist.
Genau, das war für mich so, das gehört zum Urlaub dazu.
Da stehen Windkraftanlagen, jetzt stehen die halt in jeder Landschaft.
Aber ich kann das Gefühl komplett nachempfinden.
Wir fahren in den Urlaub. Man sieht aus dem Auto heraus
ganz viele Windkraftanlagen. Genau.
Aber unsere Eltern haben natürlich einen anderen
Bezug dazu. Für die Eltern sind sie
halt irgendwann einfach aufgetaucht und standen
irgendwo, wo sie vorher nicht standen.
Und dementsprechend haben die auch
eine andere Einstellung dazu.
Für die noch älteren
Eltern? Ja. Die sterben halt auch irgendwann
weg. Für die gab es nicht mal den Braunkohletagebau.
Ich glaube, da ist
immer schon lange genug drin.
Das ist ja eh das Beste an der Regierung.
Braunkohle
der Kohleausstieg ist beschlossene Sache,
aber wir müssen ja irgendwie die Arbeitsplätze schützen,
die da von den Leuten da, die fast
20.000 Leute, die... Da haben sie mal verglichen, wie viele
Leute... Und Vierfaches davon haben wir im
Solar
Umfeld
jetzt komplett abgeschafft aus Deutschland.
Super. Fantastisch.
Das ist, glaube ich, unsere politischste Folge
bislang.
Aber lass uns doch nochmal zu klassischeren
akronomisierbar Themen zurückkommen.
Weil wir uns ja mit diesen
Politikthemen doch so ein bisschen
aufs Glatteis begeben, hin und wieder.
Ich habe da noch
einen coolen Blogpost mit in die
Show Notes gepackt. Ja.
Der ist von einem Typen namens Colin McMillan.
Der heißt
93% of Paint Splatters are valid Pearl Programs.
Der hat einfach random
Paint Splatter erzeugt und gemalt.
Paint Splatter. Also Farbe
gegen die Wand geschmissen, ein Foto von gemacht
OCR drüber laufen lassen und geschaut hat,
ob das sich in Pearl evaluieren lässt.
Und in 93% der Verlässe
halt verliebt es.
Okay, das sind wirklich Aquarellfarben
auf weißem Hintergrund hingeschrieben.
Da kommt was raus.
Das basierte auf dem Tweet von einer Person
hier, die meinte, I don't want to teach my kid
to code. I want him to splash in muddy puddles
and smear paint on the walls and read novels on other covers
way too late at night. I grew up too soon
and wish I'd had more time to be a kid. Why do schools
teach vocational skills so young these days?
Und einer hat da Kraft geantwortet mit, but is it
possible to smear paint on the wall without creating
valid pearl?
und daraus
hat er ausprobiert
und es ist fast
unmöglich.
Ich mag diesen Post,
der ist toll. Ich glaube Perl wurde
auch mit der Prämisse designt,
dass fast jede Zeichenkombination
ein valides Perl bekommen ist.
Ist das wirklich so eine Prämisse gewesen?
Aber wenn
du dir
ein gutes Passwort ausdenkst, dann ist das
wahrscheinlich auch ein valides Spur-Programm.
Da habe ich noch gar nichts drüber nachgedacht.
Passwort wird da wirklich ausführt.
Das ist so viel cooler eigentlich.
Das kannst du mal machen.
Kannst du das mal als Passwort-Requirement in irgendeinen Service reinpacken?
Dein Passwort ist kein valides Purl.
Es wird abgewiesen.
Es wird abgewiesen, weil es kein valides Purl ist.
Und es wird eben ausgeführt, um dann tatsächlich das Passwort
zu erzeugen.
Kann man das irgendwie als Plugin
in hier sowas wie KeyPassX einbauen?
Ich brauche das.
Wenn das keiner jetzt hier als Hörer noch baut,
Ich baue das selber.
Du hast nicht genügend Sonderzeichen verwendet.
Das ist noch kein Verliertes Perth.
Oh, fantastisch.
Passwort mit Verliertes Perth.
Du kannst einfach wirklich kaum
aus der Natur hauen.
Herrlich.
Okay.
So viel dazu.
Was anderes, was in letzter Zeit passiert ist,
hast du von GitHub Sponsors gehört?
Ja, ich habe da mal draufgeklickt
und direkt Gesichter von Leuten, die andere Podcasts
haben, wieder erklären.
John Griffin ist der Promiante.
Also,
um das nochmal zusammenzufassen,
GitHub macht jetzt alles.
Sie hosten jetzt auch NPM-Pakete.
Ach stimmt, Package Registry haben sie ja auch noch gemacht.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen.
Aber ich habe es mir noch nicht genau angeschaut.
Im Endeffekt,
irgendjemand hat dann so einen schönen Tweet abgesetzt,
den ich jetzt natürlich spontan nicht parat habe mit
das sind die drei Sachen, die wir
gerne von GitHub wollten.
aber nie bekommen haben. Und das waren dann ganz
banale Features von der UI, wo du
denkst, ah, das stimmt, ja, das
bräuchte man unbedingt, aber gibt's nicht.
Und was haben wir stattdessen bekommen?
Sponsoring,
Package Management und noch irgendwas,
was sie neulich aufgebaut haben.
GitHub Actions oder CI
Integration oder sowas.
Ja, die bauen jetzt relativ massiv aus. Man merkt
irgendwie doch, dass
sie den Markt
ein bisschen mehr
erschließen wollen.
Also um nochmal zu erzählen, was gibt es jetzt Neues bei GitHub?
Du kannst also dich als, wenn du deinen GitHub-Account hast, kannst du dich irgendwie sponsern lassen?
Also du kannst dich anmelden entweder als Gesponsortär oder als Sponsor.
Ich glaube, als Sponsor anmelden, also wenn du dich anmelden willst als jemand, ich mache was Relevantes und hätte dafür gerne Geld,
dann ist es ein relativ ausführliches Formular, was du da ausführst und wo du auch sagst, was genau an Projekten, was für Projekten arbeitest du,
was ist deine Rolle in diesem Projekt, was machst du da genau.
und dann ist das wahrscheinlich ein sehr manueller Prozess
auf GitHub-Seite, wo ich dann eben das
validieren vermutlich. Und ist das dann so wie
Patreon,
wo du einfach regelmäßig Geld für Leute
bekommst oder kriegst du da Geld pro Release
oder pro Commit? Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube fast, das waren feste Beträge,
die du sponsern kannst, aber vielleicht ist es auch
tatsächlich ein Abo-Modell
oder beides. Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Aber was halt besonders spannend ist,
ist, dass das komplette
erste Jahr, was du an Geld
bekommst, nimmt GitHub sich überhaupt nichts von
und sie
double es noch. Also das, was du kriegst, GitHub
legt dasselbe nochmal drauf.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht. Das finde ich echt hart.
Aber irgendwie nach einem Jahr nehmen sie dann
eine Fee oder sowas.
Ja, also die Processing-Fee, die sie halt brauchen,
um das Geld zu verschieben.
Das war gar nicht mal so wenig, waren das nicht
20 Prozent? 20?
Okay, nee, da habe ich das falsch in Erinnerung.
Wir reden mal wieder über ein Thema, mit dem wir uns doch nicht im Bereich beschäftigt haben.
Wir sprechen Themen ja bloß an,
damit andere Leute sich die dann genauer anschauen können,
wenn sie spannend sind.
Genau.
Ja, das andere, was sie gemacht haben,
was vielleicht gar nicht mal so verkehrt ist,
dass du jetzt GitHub benutzen kannst als Package Registry,
unter anderem für NPM-Pakete,
aber auch für eine Handvoll anderer Paketsysteme.
Und da fragen sich jetzt die Leute, warum?
Es ist allerdings tatsächlich interessant für Firmen,
die ihre eigene Software bauen.
Wir betreiben zum Beispiel auch unsere eigene Package Registry für intern.
der Sinn ist, dass du einfach zum Beispiel
in CI
aus deiner eigenen Package Registry
lieber ziehst, als
direkt jedes Mal von NPM
allein um nicht den NPM Download-Counter
unnötig in die Höhe zu treiben
zum anderen, weil du vielleicht
deine Dependencies wetten möchtest und
Überblick behalten möchtest, was du alles
hast oder im Zweifelsfall nachträglich reingucken möchtest
was habe ich mir da eigentlich gerade runtergezogen
Nicht bei jedem Bauvorgang, die nicht
aus dem Netzwerk irgendwelche möglicherweise
untrushed-worthy Dinge, die geupdaled wurden.
Genau, und da haben irgendwie viele Firmen,
ich glaube, das darf ich auch sagen, wir,
unter anderem einfach Artifactory.
Du kannst Artifactory als
NPM-Package-Registry eintragen.
Andere große Firmen bauen eigenes.
Oder bauen eigene.
Und das funktioniert dann eigentlich,
du kannst dann einfach alles von dort ziehen, was du auch von NPM
ziehen würdest. Die mirror nicht NPM, sondern
das funktioniert wie so eine Art Reverse-Proxy.
Schaut nach, hab ich das,
wenn nicht, dann lädst du es runter und dann kriegst du es ab.
Witzig, wenn man sich so da reinhackt.
genau, ich schätze mal
genauso hat die
jahreneigene Package Registry
von Facebook funktioniert.
Da hast du dich auch gefragt, warum ist das jetzt alles
auch plötzlich auf
dieser jahrene Package Registry anstatt auf NPM?
Und wenn du halt deine eigene
Firma hast, die vielleicht so privates GitHub
verwendet, für deine
geschlossenen Closed-Source-Projekte
und bist aber trotzdem auf GitHub.com, dann ist
das durchaus interessant dafür, dann musst du es nämlich nicht
doch wieder deine eigene
Registry hosten und das irgendwie mit
deinem privaten GitHub verschnabeln.
Man könnte es einfach sagen...
In GitHub-Enterprise-Stil mit reinbauen.
Genau. Und das ist an und für sich eigentlich ganz geil.
Mal schauen,
wie... Ich weiß nicht, ob man
das als Public Registry verwenden möchte.
Ich komme halt
aus der Swift-Welle, wo es keine Registry gibt.
Ich wäre schön, wenn es was gäbe.
Ein Index, ein Package.
Achso, bei Swift gibt es sie gar nicht.
Es gibt überhaupt nichts.
Das ist eigentlich witzig, wie sich die, das hatte ich glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt,
aber wenn man eine neue Programmiersprache erfindet, gibt es eigentlich so ein paar Features,
die unabhängig von der Programmiersprache eigentlich auch noch mit dazugehören.
Ein Bildsystem, ein bisschen so Linting, Infrastruktur, ein Paketmanager, eine Paketregistry und sowas.
Okay, zwei von vier hat zu viel.
Und viele Sprachen haben das bis heute noch nicht und sagen, wir sind eine Programmiersprache,
wir machen nur den Compiler, alles andere macht ihr selbst.
Dann denkst du dir so, ja, aber der Grund, warum ich
seit Jahren privat kein C++ nutze,
ist, weil ich einfach keinen Bock habe, mir jedes Mal
so ein Bildprojekt einzurichten mit C-Make oder so.
Und wenn eine Sprache das einfach
komplett mitbringt, dann ist das
einfach mal win-win.
Also Rust macht dafür das richtig, gerade was das angeht.
Aber na gut, man kann natürlich auch komplett ohne
Registry und Paketverwaltung
leben, vielleicht. Aber es braucht
einen Index. Es brauchst du auch nicht unbedingt,
wenn du so eine Batteries-Included-Sprache bist,
wo alles drin ist.
Das ist aber auch nicht.
Das ist aber zum Beispiel Go oder Python.
Ich habe mich zum Beispiel auch mit Leuten unterhalten,
die haben gesagt, ich mache das in Go oder Python,
weil wir bei uns Regeln haben,
wenn wir Dependencies reinziehen,
muss das alles gewettet und approved sein.
Und die Mühe möchte ich mir einfach nicht geben.
Python darf ich nehmen.
Und wenn ich was baue,
dann kann ich das auch komplett pur
mit On-Bord-Mitteln von Python machen.
und wenn ich irgendwas Spezielles brauche, dann schaue ich mir das an
und programmiere es nach.
Anstatt, dass ich mir die Dependency reinziehe.
Das ist eine Begründung.
Das ist keine gute, aber es ist eine Begründung.
Ich meine, dass man generell in die Dependencies reinschauen sollte,
sollte man eigentlich machen.
Das ist selbstverständlich, ja.
Wie genau dieser Prozess dann ausschaut,
des Wettings und des Approvals,
das kann natürlich je nach Firma sehr umständlich ekelhaft sein
und ja,
das verstehe ich, dass man sich das vielleicht nicht geben möchte.
Aber ja, also das gibt es jetzt also auch bei GitHub.
Das ist die Package Registry, genau.
Das ist die Package Registry.
So.
Was ist hier?
Famicol.
Das ist der Perl.
Achso, das ist das.
Hier steht noch ein Firefox Extension Fuckup
in der Liste, was da passiert.
Hast du das mitbekommen? Ach nee, du bist ja Safari-Nutzer.
Ist das das TLS-Dings oder was anderes?
Wir hatten ja schon lange keinen
NPM-Fuckup der Woche.
obwohl mindestens zwei passiert sind,
während wir keine Podcasts aufgenommen haben.
Diesmal gab es ein Firefox
Fuck-Up. Die genaue Geschichte kenne ich
nicht, aber das Zertifikat,
was Extensions,
die in deinem Firefox laufen,
signiert,
ist abgelaufen.
Und
die genaue Backstory
könnten wir uns mal von einem Mozilla-Mitarbeiter erzählen lassen.
Aber ich habe erst
nichts gemerkt und alle haben so geschrieben,
alle meine Extensions sind aus.
Und ich so, hä, bei mir geht's doch noch.
Und einen Tag später waren halt auch bei mir, bei einem
meiner Browser die Extensions aus.
Ist ein bisschen schade.
Aber es ging dann auch irgendwann wieder an.
Was ich ein bisschen schade
fand, ist, dass bei mir die,
ich benutze diese,
wie heißt das Feature,
diese Tab-Container, jetzt relativ
intensiv. Ist das nicht ein eingebautes Feature
mittlerweile? Das ist, nee,
das ist ein Mozilla
hausinternes Add-on,
aber es ist nicht eingebaut. Also, wie gesagt,
es gibt diese Multi-Account-Container,
so heißt es, Tabs, dass du
einen Tab aufmachen kannst, wo
deine
zum Beispiel deine GitHub-Login-Daten, deine Cookies
und die ganzen Session-Informationen weggekappelt sind.
Das gibt es
von Firefox noch extra als Facebook-Container,
was genau dasselbe ist, bloß, dass du halt
das voreingestellt hast für Facebook, dass Facebook in einem
eigenen Container aufgeht, was halt sinnvoll ist,
weil du möchtest nicht mit demselben,
mit deinen Account-Daten und deinen Session-Daten
auf anderen Seiten
browsen, weil da plötzlich irgendwelche
Facebook-Snippets drin sind.
Ich wäre sehr überrascht, wenn Facebook
da wirklich
einen Unterschied groß sieht.
Die wissen auch ohne deine
Session-Cookie,
wenn du bist.
Auch ein valides Argument,
die EU-Regulierung, dass alle Webseiten
anzeigen müssen, dass sie jetzt Cookies tracken,
das hätte ich mit Cookies tracken,
ist auch super sinnlos,
weil 10 Jahre zu spät, denn
Funktioniert mittlerweile komplett ohne Cookies.
Ja, und jetzt hast du überall einfach dieses Cookie-Banner,
was jeder wegklickt. Das macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Aber da arbeiten die Browser-Entwickler ja auch
relativ stark dagegen und versuchen diese Tracking-Eigenschaften,
mit denen man dich identifizieren kann,
weiter runterzufahren.
Ja, Apple macht auch sehr viel, genau.
Zumindest,
das hatte ich ja eingerichtet,
dann hatte ich mir irgendwie 5, 6, 7
unterschiedliche Container eingerichtet für
Shopping, Banking, GitHub, YouTube, Twitter.
Und nachdem ich das
er dann wieder installiert hatte, war leider die Einstellung
weg und ich musste mir diese ganzen Tabs neu einrichten.
Cool.
Das war ein bisschen schade.
Ich bin trotzdem noch sehr glücklicher
Firefox-Nutzer.
Nice. Ist auch schön, wenn man
seinen Browser hat.
Sein Zeitbetriebssystem der Wahl.
Auf jeden Fall.
Gerade jetzt, wo es in der Browser-Welt so ein bisschen enger wird.
Ich habe letzte Woche
auf Arbeit mal
Edge-Um ausprobiert.
Ach, Edge mit Chromium drin?
Genau, wir nennen es immer bloß Agium.
Unabhängig davon,
da schlagen irgendwie zwei Herzen in meiner Brust.
Zum einen bin ich sehr traurig, dass so die Browser weggehen.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn einfach alle auf Chrome als Backend gehen,
ist es sehr einfach, viele Browser zu unterstützen.
Was schicken die für einen User-Agent mit?
Ist ja auch wieder heilig, komplett weiter kompliziert.
Ich habe hier jetzt Microsoft Edge.
Die Nightly-Version
heißt sogar auch Canary.
Und wenn ich jetzt auf, was ist mal so eine
Seite, die mir das anzeigt,
ipchicken.com gehe,
dann
sagt er mir,
ach ja, der User-Agent-String, da wird der einfach bloß
immer hinten rangehängt. Der heißt jetzt hier
Mozilla 5
Apple Webkit KHTML,
like Gecko Chrome
Safari Edge.
Das hat nichts mit Safari zu tun.
Das hat nichts mit Apple Webkit zu tun.
Es hat auch nichts mit KHDML zu tun oder Gecko.
Aber Edge, witzigerweise hinten,
Edge ist bloß EDG,
damit es nicht auf das andere Edge matcht,
weil es ja nicht das andere Edge ist.
Achso. Das eigentliche Microsoft Edge.
Also nochmal, der Browser-Agent,
User-Agent-String ist Mozilla 5
in Klammern,
Macintosh, Intel, so und so.
Apple WebKit
in Klammern, KHDML,
KOMA, Like, Gecko,
Klammer zu, Chrome.
Version,
Was sehr sinnvoll ist, es basiert ja auf
Chrome Version
76, die ist noch gar nicht stabil.
Safari
Slash 537,
Edge 76.
Es ist schön, wie viel Historie da drin liegt.
Ich meine, man kann sich ja mal wirklich die Historie von
User-Agentings einlesen und wie die alle gesagt haben,
ja, wir sind Like Gecko, weil wir das ja Feature-Set supporten
und Blink ist ja auch ein Webkit-Fort.
Ja, das Mozilla haben sie alle bloß vorne stehen, weil es tatsächlich
mal Web-Server gab, die deinen
Browser abgelehnt haben, wenn du nicht Mozilla bist.
Also das ist
großartig, wenn man sich die History dahinter mal gibt,
aber es ist großartig bescheuert, was in
den User-Agent-String heute drin steht.
Wir empfehlen an dieser Stelle die History of the User-Agent-String.
Ja, das ist ein wirklich toller Punkt.
Was meinst du, wie die Browser in 30 Jahren aussehen?
Das ist nicht so ein 3 Megabyte User-Agent-String.
Ich glaube sogar,
ich befürchte sogar, den User-Agent-String schickst du
als Teil jedes HTTP-Requests.
Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn der
Header überall mit drin steht.
Dementsprechend ist es ganz sinnvoll, dass wir jetzt sowas wie HTTP2 haben,
wo die Header komprimiert werden.
Das finde ich übrigens schön, dass
bei iOS, ich weiß nicht, wie andere
Parfums machen, aber bei iOS, wenn du aus einer App
heraus einfach nur einen Request
schickst, ohne den User-Agent
selbst zu setzen, dann steht
im User-Agent der Name der App,
die den Request schickt. Ja, das ist sehr schön. Das finde ich super toll.
Das gefällt mir.
Witzig ist es, wenn du
mit React Native
Anwendungen baust, da
hast du einen kompletten DOM und
ein Window-Objekt und
dein JavaScript, was da
dran ausgeführt wird, aber wenn
deine App da drin versucht rauszufinden, welcher Browser
du bist, bist du auch relativ aufgeschmissen, weil die
paar Sachen einfach weglöschen, die dann normalerweise
drin vorkamen. Also du bist zum Beispiel komplett
kompatibel mit Chrome in bestimmten
Eigenschaften,
aber die normale
Browser-Erkennung, also wenn du irgendwie so ein
JavaScript-Paket installiert hast oder
in deiner App drin hast, was dir sagt, welcher Browser
du gerade bist, das sagt sich dann
...
Aber ich finde es ja schön auch, dass Microsoft jetzt Edge
für macOS wieder rausbringen will.
Das ist ja das, was ich hier gerade offen hatte.
Achso, du bist ja auch auf Mac.
Finde ich aber cool.
Es gab ja eh mal für macOS,
genauso wie Safari mal für Windows gab,
vor vielen, vielen, vielen Versionen.
Browser sollte ein plattformübergreifender sein.
Finde ich cool.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich muss hier echt,
ich halte das mal hier so her,
ich muss hier echt scharf hingucken,
um zu sehen, was Chrome,
das erkennst du nicht wirklich.
Das UI ist auch dieselbe.
Das UI ist wirklich eigentlich
das gleiche. Edge ist das linke, oder?
Das, was Bing
die Form der Form der Form der Form hat.
Ich verstehe. Genau. Also Edge ist
jetzt der Chrom mit Bing als die Formsuchmaschine.
Ja, die sehen wirklich
viel zu gleich aus. Ja, ich meine,
wenn ich jetzt noch irgendwie so ein
Firefox daneben aufmache, gut, okay.
Nee, sieht ganz anders aus.
Die UI ist ein Firefox.
Da habe ich auch so ein bisschen rumgetweakt dran. Ich glaube,
meine Developer Edition habe ich, obwohl,
nee, da ist auch, nee, das habe ich,
Warte mal, da muss ich jetzt mal hier auf Customize
gehen und hier auf
Gibt es, gab es da nicht irgendwo Reset?
Ja, wenn ich das hier wegnehme.
Restore defaults. Done.
So, jetzt machen wir den
Browser, den ultimativen Browser-Vergleich.
Super im Podcast.
Ja. So, wir haben
jetzt. Hört mal gut zu, wie wir die jetzt
beschreiben. Genau, hört mal gut zu.
Also, ich habe jetzt hier
Firefox vs. Edge.
Na, die Buttons sind ein bisschen anders.
Das sind alles dunkle UIs, die du hier hast,
weil du wahrscheinlich am Dark Mode bist.
Genau, ansonsten haben aber alle Browser mittlerweile
oben rechts dieses, du bist eingeloggt
mit diesem Account-Button. Safari nicht, warum auch?
Was ich ein bisschen eklig fand, wenn du dich
auf einer, zum Beispiel das mit diesem Tab-Container,
möchtest ja, dass deine Webseite
irgendwelche Account-Daten hat
und damit arbeitet
und das ist aber, das
möchtest du eigentlich, alles unterhalb
von der Adress-Leiste oder
Bookmark-Leiste ist die Webseite und alles oben drüber
ist Browser. Wenn du dich bei Chrome
bei Google einloggst,
auf irgendeiner Web, auf google.com oder
sowas, dann bist du auch
mit dem Chrome in Google eingeloggt.
Okay, also da machen
diese Grenze schon mal kaputt.
Als ich das gemerkt habe, weil ich mich irgendwie
auf einem meiner fünf
Google-Accounts angemeldet habe und plötzlich
mein Chrome auch da eingemeldet war,
habe ich mich so ein bisschen vergewaltigt gefühlt.
Also das war so ein
Overreach, weil das hatte noch
andere Implikationen. Das synkt dann wahrscheinlich
deine Bookmarks, deine History
und deine Passwörter vielleicht noch mit.
Und denkst du so, sag mal,
could you please not?
Ja, und das ist bei Firefox
glücklicherweise getrennt.
Und bei Edge, mal gucken.
Man kann ja bestimmt seine Bing-Suchergebnisse
verfeiern an, wenn man sich da einloggt
mit seinem Microsoft-Account.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Aber ja, es gibt jetzt zumindest
Edge-Themed Chromium.
Ich finde es schön, dass Bing immer noch den Ruf weg hat,
die Porn-Suchmaschine zu sein, weil
so viele Leute Bing nur für Porn nutzen.
Echt? Und Bing halt dementsprechend auch immer
besser für Porn.
Warum nutzen
Leute Bing für Porn? Weil sie für alles andere
Google nutzen und dementsprechend
die Ergebnisse halten.
Damit sie ihre Personalisierung
nicht...
Das ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Das war auf Reddit so ein Meme.
Wenn du nach Porn suchst, nutzt du Bing.
Ja klar, kein Mensch würde auf die Idee kommen,
bei dir auf deinem Rechner
Bing aufzumachen. Du könntest quasi
Bing auch zu deiner Pornstartseite
machen. Pornstartseite.
Immer ein Cognito-Tab
oder was?
Inseidakt, da go für alles.
Ja stimmt, die kannst du auch
eine sehr gute Porn-Suchmaschine.
Das ist viel zu allgemein, das ist ja gar nicht meine Pornfilter-Wabel,
die das Ding anlernt.
Ich habe doch
Fetische, die nicht mit der Allgemeinheit übereinstimmen.
Ja, ich stehe auf N.
Deswegen gehe ich auch immer
auf ente-ente-los.de.
Gibt es das schon?
Klar, leitet weiter auf DuckDuckGo.
Ente-ente-los.de.
Oh, shit.
Es gibt allgemein schöne Weiterleitungen zu DuckDuckGo.
Also was ich meistens eintippe, ist ddg.gg.
Das ist irgendwie das Kürzeste.
Warum kippst du das überhaupt ein?
Wenn ich irgendwo anders bin.
Ach so.
Bei meinem Rechner.
Denke ich mir immer, okay, mach mal einen Browser auf.
ich möchte mal was suchen. Ah, dann kommt natürlich sofort
hier google.com auf und dann mache ich es meistens.
Manchmal bin ich dreist, manchmal gebe ich DuckDuckGo
in das Suchfeld von Google ein und
klicke dann über Google auf DuckDuckGo.
Manchmal habe ich es einfach, bin ich
faul und dann gehe ich auf ddg.gg.
Dann gab es lange Zeit
duck.com,
was aber Google gehört hat.
Und wenn du auf duck.com gegangen bist,
bist du zu google.com
weitergeleitet worden. Witzig.
Oder umgeleitet worden.
Und jetzt vor einem Jahr oder so
haben sie die Domain abgegeben
und jetzt kommst du mit duck.com
auch einfach auf duckduckgo, glaube ich.
Ja.
Duck.com
leitet auf duckduckgo.com
slash t gleich duck.
Also dieses t ist ja dieses
mit wem, also mit welchem
Suchprovider suche ich gerade.
Ich glaube, wenn du über Firefox suchst, steht da Firefox drin.
Aha.
Du wirst also doch getrackt.
Zählen mit wie viele Leute über duckduck,
über duck.com auf duckduckgo gehen.
wollte gerade nach Fubar über Dr.
Go suchen, indem ich auf Fubar meine
URL-Leist in Safari eingeben habe, Enter gedrückt
habe und ich bin gelandet auf Fubar2000.
Ja, wenn ich einfach bloß
Fubar eingebe, wird mir Fubar2000 Deutsch
vorgeschlagen, aber ich habe hier auch gerade noch Safari
äh, Quatsch, Edge
Die Safari macht einfach
zu viel Magic, ich komme nicht an die Suche.
Und ich soll mir dann Fubar2000 auf Chip.de runterladen.
Ah, du hast recht. Ich habe
die Curry, der T-Parameter ist
OSX, was weiß ich nicht, was
OSX sagt mir nichts.
Was ist das? So heißt mein OS nicht.
Nee, stimmt. Das heißt Mac OS.
Mac OS. Ich finde die Umwendung immer noch sehr angenehm.
Sehr angenehm.
Ja, es ist halt iOS, Watch OS, TV OS,
Mac OS.
Ja, weil du ja genau
einen Mac vor dir hast, nicht ein Laptop.
Tja.
Soll das Laptop OS sein oder was?
Laptop OS heißen, oder?
Ja, aber ich habe ja auch kein iPhone.
Das ist ein iPhone.
Der Name ist halt iOS.
Obwohl es halt alles historisch wird.
Aber ist es dann nicht MOS?
Ich meine, WatchOS,
TVOS sind echt schön.
Es gibt ja noch ein Film für das OS.
Als Name, finde ich.
Die US sind...
Abgegen davon ist halt alles iOS.
Und iOS ist halt auch nur das alte Mac OS.
Hast du nicht sogar auf deinem Rechner
WatchOS auch noch laufen?
Das ist kein WatchOS, das heißt,
das ist auch nach außen hin bekannt, das ist keine
Interna, die ich hier verrate, das heißt BridgeOS,
was da drauf läuft. Das ist quasi ein
WatchOS-Derivart, soweit ich weiß, was die Touchbar
betreibt, genau. Und tatsächlich auf einem
alten, also nicht auf einem,
da ist eine alte Watch eingebaut, aber auf dem
nicht mehr aktuelle Watch-Generation CPU
ist da, glaube ich, als T2-Chip, der da
verbaut ist. Das heißt, Apple hat
einfach quasi alte WatchOS-Chips
in die
MacOS. Aber nicht, dass die noch rumlagen, also die wurden
schon dafür produziert wahrscheinlich.
Und diese... Aber ich finde es fantastisch, dass es halt
ein eigenes System ist, mit einem eigenen
OS, völlig abgesplittet. Das heißt, nichts
kommt an diesem Touch-Eye-Sensor an.
Das heißt, es kann unabhängig abstürzen.
Es kann unabhängig abstürzen.
Ist es noch nie passiert,
aber sicherlich möglich.
Ich meine, genauso hast du ja, das finde ich noch viel
fantastischer, auf den HomePod
läuft auch iOS drauf.
Auf deinen AirPods läuft auch
ein iOS-Derivat drauf.
Auf jeden AirPod einzeln.
Und du hast quasi von der Hardware...
Müssen die booten? Wie merkst du das?
Nee, nee, das merkt man nicht.
Einfach ein Minimalsystem, was den gleichen Kernel
vorwärtig ist, oder?
Es ist kein vollwertiges iOS.
Die Airpods ist ein Real-Time-OS, was da drauf läuft,
was auch super fancy ist.
Aber die CPU, glaube ich,
ist ein sehr ähnliches
Ding, wie das im iPhone 4, glaube ich,
verbaut war. Das heißt, du hast quasi zwei iPhones
in den Ohren stecken. Also mit
einem Real-Time-OS drauf, wo quasi
wirklich eine Siri-App
draufläuft. Das ist ein Siri-Damon,
der die ganze Zeit läuft, aber das ist wohl irgendwie
sehr ähnlich zu...
Das heißt, du hörst nicht nur die ganze Zeit deine Kopfhörer an.
Deine Kopfhörer hören auch noch die ganze Zeit dich an.
Ich meine, die haben ja...
Siri eingebaut, die Airpods.
Und die neue Generation ja sogar
diesen Hey Dinges Support,
dass du halt was sagen kannst.
Auch wenn das super awkward ist, weil du kein
hörbares Feedback
bekommst. Da hast du plötzlich eine Stimme im Ohr,
die sagt, ja, okay, was kann ich für dich tun?
Na, eben nicht. Du sagst einfach
Hey Dinges und dann dein Befehl.
Warum sagst du nicht, was du wirklich sagst?
Damit ich nicht hier irgendwo trigger,
wenn ich mir selber die Folge anhöre. Mich nervt das schon,
wenn Leute in irgendwelchen YouTube-Videos, die meine Freundin
daheim schaut, auf dem iPad laut, irgendwie
hey Dinges, stelle einen Timer auf so und so setzen.
Weißt du, hey Siri?
Ja.
Nicht, danke Siri, kann es wieder auflegen.
Und dann geht der HomePod plötzlich an,
okay, stelle einen Timer auf 5 Minuten.
Danke, super, klasse.
Das ist wie, bestell mir ein Kartenhaus.
Ich meine, immerhin ist der HomePod halt,
also ich bin kein Fan der Sprachresistenten.
Ich mag aber den HomePod tatsächlich sehr.
Einerseits, weil er echt doof ist.
Und ich kann sagen,
der ist von diesen ganzen drei
großen Home-Assistants
ist irgendwie der von Apple der dümmste, oder?
Also Siri ist halt mit Abstand nicht daran,
was Alexa und Google können.
Das finde ich aber auch zum einen gut so,
zum anderen ist es sehr verlässlich.
Du weißt, was es kann
und das, was es kann, macht es auch ganz gut.
Mit wenigen Ausnahmen.
Also das war witzig,
meine Freundin wollte einen Timer stellen
und so, hey Dinges, setzt einen Timer auf so und so.
Keine Antwort. Hey Dinges, setzt einen Timer auf so und so.
Keine Antwort. Hey Dinges, setzt einen verfickten Timer
auf 5 Minuten. Okay, stelle einen verfickten
Timer auf 5 Minuten. Und auf 5 Minuten
ding, ding, ding, verfickter Timer.
Super.
Habe ich das letzte Mal schon von Pico
Voice erzählt?
Wir hatten, glaube ich, schon mal drüber gesprochen. Aber ich weiß nicht mehr, ob das
anführungszeichen on air war.
Also sowas wie
man unterscheidet ja Voice Recognition,
also Wake World Recognition,
Voice Recognition und
Intent Recognition.
Achso, das ist so qualifiziert.
den Intent aus dem Text rausziehst.
Das war übrigens der eine Teil aus diesem
KI-Vortrag bei dem Meetup ab Montag,
den ich wirklich
merkenswert fand. Aber darüber hatten
wir im Detail auch schon mal gesprochen, über die ganzen
SIP-Sachen, weil der Stack da super interessant war.
Also PicoVoice ist,
du kannst jetzt hier irgendwie so ein Netzwerk
antrainieren, das war mir dann zufriediglich,
aber es gibt eine Demo auf der Webseite,
die dann Voice Recognition und Intent
Recognition kann und Wake Recognition
und das läuft dann aber komplett im Browser.
Aha. Das heißt,
ich habe hier dieses, ist wieder dieses
Ding vor mir, geht einfach mal auf PicoVoice AI.
Da gibt es unten halt
unter Products gibt es
zwei Demos.
Einmal der Wake-World-Detector.
Kannst du jetzt hier irgendwie
die Demo starten.
Dann wirst du halt mal kurz nach Access zu deinem Mikrofon
gefragt. Und dann
hast du hier so eine Glühbirne, so ein Logo.
Und dann kannst du sagen, okay, Lamp. Und dann siehst du, dass das
angeht. Yellow.
Und dann stellt er das um.
Und das läuft komplett offline. Das fand ich gut.
Das habe ich bei meinem WebAssembly-Vortrag
erwähnt. Und warum?
Also ich meine, als Tag-Demo cool,
will ich irgendwann Spracherkennung und
Intent-Parsing im Browser haben?
Es geht ja nicht darum, dass es
im Browser brauchst, sondern
dass es im Browser geht.
Oder mal da abgesehen, das kann ja Teil von
deiner Anwendung sein, tatsächlich. Viele Leute
bauen ja Anwendungen,
die wirklich komplett auf dem Browser basieren.
Kann ich mit meinem Support-Bot jetzt reden, oder was?
Zum Beispiel
du gehst oft in die
Webseite, die hat noch da immer mal diese Anna
oder sowas eingeblendet, auch so eine KI,
mit der du reden konntest und der du sagen konntest,
ich suche jetzt Sessel in Nila.
Und der kann
dann sagen, ich suche jetzt hier sowas
oder sowas. Also ich glaube, für manche
ist das schon spannend. Aber zumindest hier siehst du
noch, das ist die eine Demo.
Das erkennt also wirklich bloß, dass du okay Lamp sagst
und dann kannst du irgendwie eine Farbe sagen und dann
leuchtet dieses Bild hier im Hintergrund. Dann gibt es auch
hier unten noch diese Kaffeemaschine
und das ist das Keyword
Hey Barista.
und dann kannst du sagen, ich hätte gerne ein Cappuccino
mit Milch.
Das habe ich natürlich auf Deutsch gesagt,
deswegen hat er mich wahrscheinlich nicht verstanden.
Aber er sagt jetzt
I didn't understand your command.
Nochmal, Start-Demo.
Hey Barista,
make me an Espresso with Milk.
Ich glaube,
das Hebarista kommt.
Hey Barista,
make me an Espresso with Milk.
Und dann merkt er,
dann hast du hier unten aus die Auswahl
dann siehst du, dass er diesen und jeden Button drücken soll.
Also generell sind auch so parametrisierte Sachen
finde ich super cool. Also wenn du halt wirklich
so rausziehst noch mit hier extra
Informationen wie, der Intent ist so und so
und da sind halt diese beiden Variablen, die ich
brauche. Da wird es halt echt spannend,
sobald du sowas damit machen kannst, finde ich.
Genau.
Ich habe, wo ich gerade bei SupportBots war,
ich hatte letztens diese schöne Unterhaltung, ich habe ja
immer noch dabei, meine Steuern für
die USA zu feilen.
Das ist ja immer noch nicht durchgegangen. Ich habe letztens mit der iOS
telefonieren dürfen, tolles Telefonat.
Ich habe jetzt nochmal mit einer Firma, die die Steuererklärung gemacht hat,
nochmal Kontakt aufgenommen, hatte leider nur erstmal deren Chatbot vor mir.
So, hi there, this is Chatbot, how may I help you today?
Ich habe meine Nachricht direkt reingepastet, weil ich der Meinung war,
das geht bestimmt gleich weiter an den Human Agent.
Und dann kommt der Chatbot, I've got, ja, Werbateam, so wie ich die Nachricht,
I've got you some relevant questions that may help.
Is your question similar to any of the questions below?
Eine question, keine question, steht einfach nur, you cannot help.
Klickst du drauf auf You cannot help, wird die Nachricht eingefüllt in den Chat.
You cannot help. Oh, I'm sorry, I could not help.
Please click on the button below to chat to an agent.
Wow. Was eine Interaktion.
Das ist aber doch jedes Mal so, wenn du zum Beispiel bei irgendeinem Telekom-Telefondienst anrufst,
wo du erstmal deine Telefonnummer eintippen darfst nochmal und dann sagst du Ja, Nein, Ja.
Das ist das, was ich an den Sprachassistenten eigentlich am kritischsten finde. Mit dem momentan eingeschränkten Funktionsumfang, den sie haben und der Qualität, ist es halt nicht so, dass sie sich in unser Leben eingliedern und so ein Assistent für uns sein, sondern dass sie eher uns dazu zwingen, uns der Maschine anzupassen.
wenn du mit so einem Gerät redest,
meine Eltern haben auch eine Alexa zu Hause
und die sagen dann, Alexa,
Küchenlicht aus. Alexa, Küchenlicht an.
Und ich gehe da hin und sage, Alexa,
mach mal das Licht in der Küche bitte aus.
So, einfach einen normalen Satz, den du sagen würdest.
Sag doch einfach das.
Nee, ich sehe einfach nicht ein,
dass ich meine Sprache der Maschine anpasse.
Nee, ich persönlich finde es besser, das nicht anzupassen,
weil ich will klar mit einer Maschine
reden und nicht mit etwas, was ich
zu sehr anthropomorphisiere.
Ja, das ist auch schon wieder recht.
Also solange das Ding keine wirkliche,
also ich meine, wir sprechen von künstlicher Intelligenz,
das ist halt nichts, was auch nur annähernd eine künstliche
Intelligenz ist. Das ist quasi
eine Reihe von If-Else-Statements. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen mehr,
das ist wirklich ein Machine Learning Model-Leiter, aber das ist so
doof wie eine Reihe von If-Else-Statements.
Das ist, also der Begriff
künstliche Intelligenz ist noch 50 Jahre zu früh.
Ich meine, das mit dem mal bitte,
ist jetzt übertrieben, muss nicht bitte zu dem Gerät
sagen müssen, aber ich möchte einen Satz formulieren
können, der mir jetzt mal rausrutscht
und nicht in irgendwelche
nicht in irgendwelche Muster verfallen, wo ich dem Ding
immer wieder, wenn ich immer
das Licht damit anfache, immer wieder
einen vorformulierten Satz, den ich mir mal geprägt
habe, weil ich weiß, dass er funktioniert,
sagen muss, bloß damit das
funktioniert.
Dann werde ich nämlich zur Maschine.
Ich nutze auch immer, hey Siri, danke,
um
Wow, das war
unerwartet, meine Uhr.
Deswegen sage ich es nicht.
Um Timer zu beenden.
weil ich halt weiß, dass das funktioniert
aber es ist halt ein Wort
und ich würde
stopp, funktioniert genauso, nein, nein, hör auf
ähm
was ich eigentlich
vorhin sagen wollte, ist, dass
das Mitnimmenswerte von diesem Vortrag über
künstliche Intelligenz war
das Periodensystem der KI
und
das wurde irgendwie von Bitcoin aus gearbeitet
und das ist einfach, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Periodensystem
aber
es ist
es ist einfach eine
Klassifikation der unterschiedlichen Derivate
von künstlicher Intelligenz, die es gibt.
Ah, okay. Und Ausprägung. Also es fängt hier an
mit, ähm,
von links nach rechts SR und
SI, da kommt erst Speech Recognition
und danach,
jetzt falte ich die Sikus schon, Speech
Identification, das ist das gleiche dann für
Audio Recognition,
Audio, diese Animation,
Identification und
so weiter und dann,
also es fängt immer mit Recognition und dann
Identification an und gibt es wahrscheinlich eine nächste
Ausbruchstufe, ist dann Intent Recognition und so weiter und so fort.
Ist das Intent Recognition?
Ist hier unten, also das ist nicht ganz wirklich
aber Image Recognition.
Stimmt, gibt es Intent?
Nö, das ist doch hier gar nicht.
Also es ist wahrscheinlich nicht vollständig, aber diese Klassifikation
Das ist ein anderer Begriff, den ich dafür nutze.
Ich vermute, ich nutze einfach ein anderer Begriff dafür.
Das ist ein deutscher Begriff für Intent Recognition.
Aber die heißt Speech Identification.
Wahrscheinlich Speech Identification dann, ja.
Also es ist Periodensystem-
KI.de. Fand ich ganz witzig.
Können wir durchschauen.
Genau, also
den Webmontag
gibt es jetzt erstmal
doch wieder eine Weile nicht. Nachdem sie den
nach einer Weile jetzt aus der Versenkung geholt
haben, haben sie gleichzeitig gesagt, ja, aber
im Sommer sind meistens nicht so viele
Meetups. Also werden wir vielleicht ab
August, September
vielleicht mal wieder eins machen. Haben aber direkt
vorgemerkt, dass ich dann da rede und meinen
WebAssembly-Vortrag dort nochmal halte. Ich werde
allerdings bis dahin wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen aktualisieren
und weiterentwickeln, weil es sich
noch ein paar Felder ergeben. Ich werde den
wahrscheinlich auch dann weniger technisch und weniger rustig
halten, sondern vielleicht eher so ein bisschen
über die Möglichkeiten und Zukunft
davon reden.
Also wer sich dafür interessiert und mich dann
mal hören würde,
merkt euch mal den Webmontag.
Das ist atwebmontag.dd
auf Twitter und wenn die bekannt geben, dass das wieder ist,
werde ich da wahrscheinlich der ersten
Redner sein.
Ich finde es cool.
Genau. Apropos unsere Hörer,
ich fand es übrigens sehr cool, dass wir
letzte Woche unseren
neuen Matrix-Channel angesprochen haben
und instant sechs Leute
diesem Channel beigetreten sind
und da jetzt tatsächlich über die
gesprochen wird, fand ich mega
cool. Auf jeden Fall.
Also akkonomisierbar
colonmatrix.org
also router akkonomisierbar colonmatrix.org
Die Adressen lassen sich nicht schön vorlesen
von dem Matrix-Channel, aber
auf dem Standard-Matrix-Home-Server
Chrome-Server, dann herrscht
Rautark-Konditioner der Raum.
Ich merke gerade, dass ich auf meinem Laptop gar nicht
eingeloggt bin auf dem Ding. Ich habe es bloß zu Hause.
Deswegen schaue ich da immer bloß abends rein,
wenn ich schon im Abschaltmodus bin.
Oder am Wochenende.
Das muss ich mir immer auf meinen Laptop ziehen hier.
Mach mal. Und auf dein Handy.
Achso, auf dem Handy habe ich es. Ja, das stimmt.
Achso. Aber mein Handy ist so
belastet von so vielen Messengern.
Neulich hat mir irgendjemand geschrieben,
weil es sich abends mit mir treffen wollte,
auf Telegram, weil ich halt Telegram
weil es im ASCII verwendet wird, halt leider
jetzt mittlerweile doch installiert habe.
Das ist ja gewundert, warum ich nicht geantwortet habe,
weil ich irgendwie Telegram irgendwie immer so
geh weg.
Und das ist,
ich weiß, da haben wir schon vor zwei Jahren
drüber geredet hier. Wir müssen übrigens mal
den Schmittlauch einladen und wirklich über
Messenger quatschen, der hat da auch ein paar
Ansichten.
Noch mehr Messenger?
Ich glaube auch generell ein paar Ansichten zu Jabba
und Bekanntenprotokollen.
Ja, also wenn es nächste Woche, nächstes Mal
Wenn es bei der nächsten Folge nicht Sascha ist,
dann Herr Schmidloch.
Der grüßt mich immer nicht.
Ich sehe den manchmal in der Stadt.
Und dann bin ich so,
das ist...
Vielleicht weiß der nicht, wie ich aussehe.
Ja, dieses Messenger-Thema
ist leid. Wir hatten ja schon ganze Folgen drüber gemacht
und irgendwie wird es nicht weniger.
Aber ich meine,
was soll denn da passieren? Bei E-Mails
gab es auch irgendwie
vorher fünf Standards und irgendwann haben sie
einfach alle gesagt, wir besprechen uns einen Standard.
und plötzlich kannst du von deiner
CompuServe E-Mail-Adresse
an deine AOL.com E-Mail-Adresse
E-Mails schicken. Ich wäre echt nicht überrascht,
wenn Google das demnächst kaputt macht.
Die haben ja jetzt AMP vor Gmail eingeführt
und noch
machen ja Gmail immer mehr zu einer
Sache, die nur Gmail ist.
Du meinst, es ist nicht
so, dass sich die Messenger dem E-Mail-System
annähern und die
ganzen Silos einreißen, sondern
dass es wahrscheinlich bei E-Mails wieder Silos geben wird.
Ich vermute fast. Es würde mich wirklich nicht wundern,
wenn Google irgendwann demnächst sagt,
vielleicht nicht ganz so demnächst,
aber innerhalb der nächsten 10 bis 15 Jahre
Gmail nur noch zu Gmail senden und empfangen kann.
Das würde mich echt nicht wundern.
Überhaupt nicht.
Oder dass du vielleicht so ein E-Mail-Gateway für Gmail kriegst,
dass du vielleicht ab und zu noch eine E-Mail damit empfangen kannst,
aber eigentlich sollst du es nicht mehr nutzen.
Sonst ist es halt das Gmail-Ecosystem.
Wie gesagt, würde mich wirklich überhaupt nicht wundern.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn ich jetzt hier nochmal
so eine Inventur
mache,
von was ich so an Messengern hier drauf
habe. Ich gehe mal einfach alles
durch.
Ich habe jetzt
hier, ich zähle mal Instagram mit.
Ich habe mir auch nach dem Mobile Camp
zum Spaß mal, weil einer erzählt hat, ich arbeite jetzt bei
Lavoo. Habe ich mir mal Lavoo installiert?
Ich würde das mal als Messenger
zählen. Ich habe jetzt hier
Old Riot EM
heißt das bei mir. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum.
Dann habe ich Riot EM.
Ich habe, glaube ich, beide installiert gehabt.
Die sehen gleich aus. Witzig.
dann habe ich wie gesagt Signal, dann habe ich Slack
dann habe ich Telegram
dann habe ich WhatsApp
dann habe ich Wire, die sammeln sich hier
weiter unten alle
das ist echt
und ich habe schon Sachen aussortiert
das ist
traurig
es gibt sehr viele Messenger
ich hoffe immer noch
Riot macht echt Fortschritt
ich hoffe, dass das Matrix wirklich was wird
aber wir lassen das Thema nicht heute anschneiden
sondern.
Wie beim Arzt halt,
beobachten und abwarten.
Mal schauen.
Bis es sich hoffentlich richtig entwickelt.
Ja gut, okay, also dann, damit waren wir an dieser
Stelle dann auch mit dem
aber ich glaube, wir haben auch echt schon eine Weile heute
gehört, oder? Ja.
Hast du noch irgendeine GitHub-Empfehlung?
Ich habe hier ein Repo offen,
das heißt,
jetzt wollen wir das Thema Wahl schon durch haben,
Analyzing the Valomat
about the 2019
European Union Election.
Da hat einer sich alle Valomat-Daten
genommen,
die Antworten der Parteien, die Zustimmung
und Gegenstimmen und Neutralstimmen,
das ist eigentlich wenig bei Parteien,
und die
gegenübergestellt und
somit ein paar schöne Visualisierungen
gemacht, welche Parteien sich
im politischen Spektrum sehr nahe
sind und wo Parteien generell
einzuordnen sind, das fand ich großartig.
Generell, wenn wir die...
Die haben quasi die nach den Antwortmöglichkeiten
geclustert, oder was? Genau, also es gibt hier
drei Visualisierungen.
Die hier,
die dritte ist hier quasi so eine
Übersicht über die, nach wirklich
wo er versucht hat, das politische Spektrum
nach links und rechts zu schieben.
Und da hast du die linkestmögliche Partei
hier, dieses
DiEM25 und die Grünen.
Die liegen quasi auf einen Punkt, was ein bisschen
interessant ist. DiEM25.
Und die AfD ganz rechts.
Natürlich.
Und dann vieles
dazwischen geclustert, die CDU,
FDP da ganz unten,
die Unionsparteien.
DKP ist da oben links,
der dritte Weg ist rechts oben.
Also du hast hier wirklich,
witzigerweise die ganzen Tierschutzparteien
sind überall.
Die Rechte und die AfD.
Es ist auch die Frage, was genau heißt hier rechts?
Er hat sich versucht,
hier die einzelnen Standpunkte
politisch zu gliedern,
ob die eher rechts oder links zu finden sind
und dementsprechend dieses Diagramm dann gezeichnet.
Aber du hast halt auch in dem ersten Diagramm sehr gut sichtbar,
welche Parteien sich inhaltlich sehr nahe sind.
Und das ist auch super interessant.
Obwohl man natürlich beim Wahlumalten immer bedenken muss,
dass die AfD da immer relativ gut bei wegkommt,
da die einfach nicht Antworten liefern mit dem, was sie machen würden
oder wie sie agieren würden als Partei,
sondern die Antworten einfach mit dem, wo sie denken,
das wollen die meisten Leute hören.
Wie bei diesem Fahrrad-Symposium.
Da war ein AfDler
da, der hat tatsächlich erzählt, dass sie
irgendwie autofreie Straßen in Dresden haben.
Das ist so ein Gegenteil von dem, was auf den
Wahlplakaten steht. Das ist exakt das Gegenteil.
Ich meine, so funktioniert das.
Aber gut, okay, es ist
wirklich eine sehr politische Sendung.
Erstaunlich so. Aber hast du
eigentlich, apropos Wahl-O-Mat,
ich fand das ja echt toll, muss ich
sagen, von der Volt-Partei, dass
die den Wahl-O-Mat also nicht verklagt,
aber die haben ja quasi das Bundesamt für politische Bildung
da vor das Gericht gezogen,
beziehungsweise gesagt, dass es halt nicht in Ordnung ist,
dass man da nur mit acht Parteien vergleichen kann.
Das stört mich auch schon seit Jahren.
Ich ärgere mich selbst darüber,
dass ich halt nie auf die Idee gekommen bin,
da irgendwo mal irgendwo was anzumerken.
Aber das ist halt generell so ein Feature,
was halt wirklich gerade Kleinparteien schadet,
weil Kleinparteien halt selten in die Auswahl fallen.
Und das merke ich auch an mir selber.
Ich wollte eigentlich immer nur meine Aussagen vergleichen
mit den großen Parteien, die ich kenne
und mit den Parteien, die ich schon wusste,
dass ich die wähle, also quasi Piraten,
Partei, Linke, die halt damit reinziehen.
Und dass es die gerade geschafft haben,
überhaupt zu einer großen Partei zu werden,
ist eigentlich ein Wunder, wenn du dir anguckst,
wie mit Parteien so umgegangen wird.
Aber die meisten Leute vergleichen halt nicht mit der Partei.
Gerade wenn du halt sowas für die Europawahl hast,
wo du auch keine 5%-Hürde hast,
wo du halt wirklich wählen kannst, wen du möchtest,
was du generell auch machen solltest,
die Partei wählst, die am ehesten
mit deiner Ansicht übereinstimmt,
Aber wenn du halt nicht weißt,
wenn du halt eine Liste von 30 Parteien hast,
du gehst nicht alle Programme durch, du schaust dir nicht alle an,
das wird nicht passieren. Und auch wenn das Bundesamt
für politische Bildung das nicht will, nutzen Leute
den Wahl-O-Maten halt explizit dafür, um
rauszufinden, was so richtig will.
Ja genau, und auch wenn es explizit ist, das ist keine
Wahlempfehlung, es ist halt ein prima Tool,
um zu sehen, welche Parteien ich mir
denn genauer anschauen sollte. Und wenn ich
da halt nur diese beschissene kleine Auswahl
habe von acht Parteien, von wo sie
halt immer rumgelogen haben, dass es eine technische
Grundlage ist, das halt nicht besser geht,
Ist halt Bullshit.
Vor allem war es halt, glaube ich, im Frontend-Java-Skript
konntest du das Limit setzen, wie du möchtest.
Da war eine Variable, wo du einfach einstellen konntest,
wie viele Parteien du
für die Auswahl haben wolltest.
Dann sind plötzlich noch andere Parteien aufgetaucht?
Nee, dann konntest du mehr als acht Parteien auswählen.
Ach so.
Das war einfach eine Konstantin, die da im Internet ausgeführt hat.
Und die Partei hatte halt,
nachdem der Wahl-O-Mat dann kurzzeitig offline war,
den Partei-O-Mat gestartet.
Eine wunderschön, super flinke,
schnieke kleine Bootstrap-Anwendung.
Da fällt mir noch was ein, was ich eh habe.
Wo du halt einfach schnell durchklicken kannst,
du vergleichst mit allen Parteien.
Die haben halt witzig, die Partei stand immer ganz oben,
egal wie viel Prozent die hatten.
Aber du kannst ja natürlich im Kopf selber umsortieren.
Auch wenn die Parteien drunter mehr Prozente hatten,
die Partei schneidet bei mir trotzdem immer...
Gar nicht so trivial zu implementieren.
Ja, die Partei schneidet bei mir trotzdem immer recht gut ab.
Das ist auch eine tolle Partei.
Witzig fand ich auch, dass die DieVolt-Partei,
die waren nicht ausgegraut, aber blurry.
erst wenn du draufgeklickt hast,
konntest du den sehen. Das war halt so ein witziger kleiner
Seitenhieb. Aber ich meine, das war halt auch ein gewisser Fokus
für dich. Also kann man sich nicht beschweren, dass das irgendwie
ein Meinungsmacher wäre. Aber ich fand es
toll, dass der Partei-O-Mat halt instant
online war. Das ist ein super tolles Ding gewesen.
Fand ich großartig.
Geil. Die Partei macht sowieso
witzige technische Sachen. Die haben wir diesen
URL-Schortner rausgebracht.
Ja, diesen fckaf.de
fckaf.de
Genau. Großartig.
Da kannst du dich sogar auswählen. Ich meine,
Normalerweise sollte ich ja in URL-Shorten
oder so schnell wie möglich weiterleiten.
Bei dem fckhf.de kannst du auswählen,
wie lange dir der Text fckhf.de angezeigt wird,
bevor du weitergeleitet wirst auf deine eigentliche Seite.
Fantastisch.
Finde ich ganz großartig.
Es gab noch den Digitalomat.
Was ist das?
Der Digitalomat wird von, ich weiß gar nicht,
der wurde zumindest auf Logbuch Netzpolitik empfohlen.
Und da wird nicht das Parteiprogramm analysiert,
weil normalerweise der Wahlomat hat ja auch noch
Dickpunkt, dass sie einfach bloß das analysieren, was die Leute von sich
behaupten, dass sie tun.
Was die Parteien von sich behaupten, dass sie machen
würden, wenn sie gewählt werden würden.
Der Digitalomat ist
relativ fokussiert auf Netzpolitik und
auf Digitalpolitik.
Wie sie es bisher haben.
Und genau beinhaltet, wie die Parteien
sich in Vergangenheit bei Abstimmungen
verhalten haben.
Das ist natürlich auch diskriminierend gegenüber
neuen Parteien, die sich zum
ersten Mal aufstellen. Aber
es ist wesentlich
näher an der Wirklichkeit als der
Valomat. Das finde ich aber toll.
Sagen wir jetzt alles, nachdem die Europawahl vorbei ist.
Gut.
Die Folge hätte man früher leider nicht rausbekommen.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe hier noch, wo wir ja eigentlich gerade
bei den GitHub-Stars sind,
mal wieder auf was Zähnchen zu kommen.
Es gibt eine weitere DVB-Library.
Uuuuh.
Nämlich von Sepp Dene DVB-MQTT.
Das ist in Go geschrieben
und das
fragt die DVB-E-Pfile
API ab und bietet ein
MQTT-Interface an.
Das ist ja schick.
Das gefällt mir sehr.
Aber es ist quasi
ein MQTT-Proxy quasi
für DVB-Daten.
Also kannst du nicht subscriben auf einzelne Dinge,
quasi Channels für Haltstellen oder was?
Ich will das hier nicht zu hoch loben, das sind
60-Zeilen-Quote, aber ich wollte es mal
erwähnen.
Der Ding kommt in das VVO-Report mit rein.
Auf jeden Fall, mach das mal.
Sehr geil.
Ich wollte letztens tatsächlich mal, ich hätte mal mit der Idee gespielt, ob man irgendwie ein GraphQL Frontend für DVB-Daten basteln könnte,
beziehungsweise ein GTFS Realtime Proxy.
Gerade für sowas wie die DVB-Daten, wo du ja diverse Sachen miteinander korrelieren möchtest als Nutzer,
nämlich was kommt an welchen Haltestellen für eine Bahn, wo fährt die dann hin, wie komme ich darüber abgeleitet von A nach B,
wie lange dauert das, wenn ich dieses und jenes kombiniere.
Das ist ja die perfekte Anwendung
für GraphQL. Du musst ja nur
anbieten, was wann wo fährt
und den Rest kann sich der Client eigentlich
herleiten. Naja, du hast halt auch unterschiedliche
Queries, die du stellen möchtest, aber
ich hab mich halt, glaube ich, generell ein bisschen zu viel in GraphQL
verliebt in den letzten Wochen.
Zum Beispiel diese, gerade die
DVB oder die VVO-API
ist eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel für
ein REST-API,
die an ihre Grenzen gekommen ist.
Allein aufgrund der kombinatorischen Vielfalt
und wo sich GraphQL
sehr gut für anbieten würde.
Ich denke fast auch, aber ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das wirklich so ist.
Du hast halt relativ gut
definierte Interfaces, gerade wenn du halt
GTFS-Daten hast und wenn du GTFS-Real-Time-Daten hast,
dann ist eigentlich alles da und dann kannst du da wirklich
alles mit drauf aufbauen.
Und ich weiß nicht,
aber ich würde halt trotzdem gerne, weil ich persönlich gerne
die sehr heterogene
Clients schreibe, die
unterschiedliche Daten haben wollen, einfach
Das ist GraphQL halt klasse.
Das ist halt die geilste Idee.
Womit schreibst du
GraphQL-Clients?
Aktuell halt aus,
da muss ich mich halt noch auseinandersetzen,
ich habe ausschließlich aktuell GraphQL-Erfahrung
immer noch mit PostGraphile, was das direkt
auf eine Postgres-Datenbank aufbaut
und das Schema quasi aus dem
DB-Schema generiert. Das heißt, ich habe
noch den GraphQL-Server noch nicht
selber implementiert.
Aber den Client baust du,
du schreibst quasi GraphQL, aber eigentlich
macht eher Postgres-Anfragen.
Der macht im Hintergrund,
der liegt einfach auf der Datenbank drauf und macht jetzt die passenden
SQL-Querries.
Cool.
Und das ist halt, also, weil das halt was raus...
Aber dann ist das ja der Aufsatz auf die
GraphQL, also dann ist der
ja quasi der GraphQL-Anbieter, oder?
Weil du schreibst...
Dieses Postgrefile ist der GraphQL-Server.
Genau.
Und der übersetzt quasi das angefragte GraphQL-Schema
in eine Reihe von Datenbank-Abfragen,
die er machen muss.
Was benutzt du als Client-Library?
unterschiedlich. Ich habe ein bisschen mit Apollo rumgespielt
und aber für andere Sachen kannst du
auch einfach, wenn du feste Queries hast
und dann nichts groß, wo der Client viel
rumnavigieren muss, kannst du auch wieder was in den Sources schicken.
Ja eben, du schickst einfach hartgecodete Queries,
die halt minimals parametrisiert
werden und
kriegst einfach eine Antwort, die du halt als Schema
so auseinanderpickst.
Ich meine, du musst ja nicht, als jeder Client,
musst nicht komplett deine API
da inspizieren können. Wenn der Client sehr spezifisch für irgendeine Domäne
ist, das ist ja wunderbar, wenn der einfach seine Anfrage
geschickt eine Antwort bekommt. Aber der Server kann
halt diverse Anfragen
beantworten.
Ne, finde ich
immer noch sehr cool. Aber ich hätte
auch, wie gesagt, gerne einfach GTFS
Proxy quasi, GTFS Real-Time
Proxy für VVO-Daten, weil man dann
das in andere Tools reinfüttern kann, die mit
GTFS, weil alles, was mit ÖPNV
zu tun hat, mit GTFS-Daten zurechtkommt.
Warum kriege ich vom scheiß
VVO-DVP keine
GTFS-Daten? Warum nicht? Warum kriegt
die nur Google? Was soll die Scheiße?
Verträge?
Stört mich tierisch. Priorisierung?
Ja, aber nee, Priorisierung,
die Daten sind da.
Scheiß drauf, dass die Google
kriegen. Das hat nichts mit Priorisierung zu tun, das ist einfach nur
arschig. Also dann doch
irgendwelche Verträge wahrscheinlich.
Gut, soviel zum Thema
VVO. Ich habe noch
eine Kleinigkeit, die hier bei uns auf Arbeit
habe ich das das letzte Mal schon erwähnt. Renovate Bot?
Nee.
Ich habe
zu Hause, würde ich sagen. Ich habe jetzt bei uns auf Arbeit
einen Renovate-Bot eingerichtet, den kannst du auf GitHub
schon einfach so nutzen. Das ist ein Bot,
der deine Pakete
anguckt. Das ist natürlich
der Voraussetzung, dass du
eine Sprache verwendest, die
eine Package-Registry und
Pakete mit so einer
Manifest-Datei
dient. Also alles außer Go.
Alles außer, also bei
Swift würde es dann dementsprechend vielleicht auch gehen.
Du hast ja versionierte Pakete,
Du hast bloß keinen Index, wo du nachschauen kannst.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob er Swift unterstützt.
Das ist halt komplizierter, weil es halt ausführbar ist.
Bei Swift ist es komplizierter, weil er Swift ausführen muss.
Aber
RenovateBot, dem sagst du, hier komm,
das ist mein Repo. Und dann sagt er,
gut, okay. Und dann kriegst du
von dem ein Onboarding Pull Request.
Der legt dir einfach bloß
eine Renovate JSON
in dein Paket mit rein.
Oder in dein Repo mit rein.
Und dann kannst du dann darüber noch
so ein bisschen konfigurieren, wie du, was weiß ich,
Commit-Nachrichten haben möchtest
oder in welcher Frequenz und dann kriegst du
ab da von dem Renovate-Bot
Pull-Requests mit Package-Updates,
mit Dependency-Updates. Ach, der macht direkt
PRs dafür? Der öffnet dir
Pull-Requests, die deine, einfach deine Dependency-Updates haben.
Und da wird dann in dem PR die CI ausgeführt, du siehst,
ob die Tests noch laufen. Genau.
Der muss echt nicht mehr machen, als sich ab und zu
deine Package-JSON angucken und zu schauen,
oh, da gibt es hier schon eine
Zahl größer.
Äh, erinnere ich mal, mache ich Pull-Requests und ob das
funktioniert oder nicht, das musst du deine CI
rausfinden. Beziehungsweise musst du rausfinden, was ja auch völlig
legitim ist, das sollst du ja auch rausfinden.
Aber wenn du eh schon
eine CI laufen hast, die validiert, dass dein
Projekt kompiliert und die Tests alle laufen,
bevor du was mercht,
dann ist das komplett
painless.
Was ähnliches haben sie jetzt in GitHub selber bereits eingebaut
mit Dependibot.
Da habe ich mir gar nicht so genau angeguckt, das habe ich jetzt vor ein paar Tagen
gehört. Aber RenovateBot
kannst du auch selber bei dir, wir haben es einfach
als Jenkins-Job laufen, alle halbe
oder sowas, geht der seine Liste
an Repositories durch, die wir bei ihm eingetragen
haben und sagt, okay, du kriegst jetzt
ein Update.
Super nice, der beim ersten, bei diesem
Onboarding-Pull-Request sagt er dir direkt,
also ich
mache dir jetzt
dieser Pull-Request hier beinhaltet plus diese
Config-Datei und wenn du den mergst, dann bin ich
dafür dieses Repo freigeschalten und dann
bekommst du, das weiß ich jetzt schon, noch diese
Liste von weiteren Pull-Requests, die ich dir
jetzt noch nicht stelle. Und dann siehst du direkt,
oh mein Gott, der macht mir 15 Pull-Requests auf,
Ich sollte vielleicht erstmal meine Dependencies alle updaten,
bevor ich den Porta draufschmeiße.
Und
dann pinnt der irgendwie noch
deine Dependencies, dann macht er diese Carrots
und Tildes von deinen Dependencies weg,
weil die sind ja jetzt immer hart aktuell.
Ah, okay.
Zumindest bei Dev-Dependencies, bei JavaScript
macht das so, bei Live, also
bei Deployten-Dependencies
nicht, weil deine, wenn du
in der Library bist oder sowas, sollen sich ja deine Benutzer
aussuchen können, welche Dependencies sie nehmen.
Und
danach kriegst du eigentlich so alle
paar Stunden, Tage
immer mal so ein Pre-Request mit. Ach,
übrigens, da gibt es eine neue Version von so.
Da wirst du auch richtig vor, vergisst man es halt und merkt es nicht.
Schön finde ich auch, in den Pre-Request
steht immer drin, hier Link zur Homepage
von dieser Version, das und das hat sich geändert.
Auch wenn die Chainzog direkt mit reinlinks in den PR,
das wäre natürlich noch.
Das kriegen sie nicht hin, aber dadurch,
dass viele Repos, also es linkt sich einmal
zum Repo und einmal zur Homepage
und die Repos haben halt meistens
oder so ein
ChangeLog MD oder sowas mit drin.
Das ist ja auch eigentlich ein gut, also bei den meisten
ein gut spezifizierendes Format.
Wenn es diese Konvention gibt, man müsste in die Package Registries
noch in diese Manifest-Datei noch überall
den ChangeLog mit verlinken,
dann könnte man das machen. Ohne weiteres.
Das finde ich cool.
Könntest du sagen, hier, ChangeLog, das und das hat sich geändert.
Und dann geht der ganze Scheiß von alleine.
Also wenn ihr irgendwie
so selber Pakete verwaltet,
dann
mach doch das mal.
Das ist gleich wieder ein lästiger Arbeitsschritt,
den ihr frühmorgens beim ersten
Kaffee im Büro macht,
wieder wegautomatisiert.
Der muss ja zum Beispiel für
Swift gar kein Swift ausführen.
Der muss ja wirklich bloß das Git-Repo
pullen und aufs Tag schauen.
Das war's.
Der muss sich deine Dependency-Liste angucken können.
Ah, I see. Das ist korrekt.
Ja, hast recht.
Und dazu muss er, das Ding selber ist in
JavaScript geschrieben, also ich weiß nicht, ob es bereits
Warte. Ich meine,
er muss ja quasi nur die CLI callen.
Wer ist das Swift Package?
Ich gehe jetzt mit
DuckDuckGo auf, Ausrufezeichen,
NPM. Ich liebe die Bangs.
Bangs sind das geilste DuckDuckGo.
Allein deswegen kannst du kein Google mehr benutzen.
Google hat keinen Bangs.
Aber sie haben
diese Instant Answers irgendwann nachgezogen.
Was aber auch
kritisiert wurde. Es gibt Nifty Package
Swifty Ravage. Das klingt ja
nach dem Autogen erritten.
Ja, das ist alles ein bisschen, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich
sogar... Ja, aber du wirst ja nicht...
Ich hab mich gerade gefragt, ob es schon
ein JavaScript
Library gibt, die
Swift-Manifest-Dateien...
Das sind fünf Zeilen JavaScript.
Du führst einmal Swift-Package,
dump-Swift...
Ja, ne...
Dump-Package heißt es, glaube ich, tatsächlich.
Ja, aber es sitzt voraus, dass du Swift hast.
Ja, du musst auf deiner CI halt, da wo du
das Ding halt ausführst haben.
Das geht vielleicht sogar, ja.
Dumpst du das JSON raus, das liest du aus.
Wenn Swift-Ziel-Package-Manager
bringt dir direkt ein Dump-das-Manifest
als JSON mit Command.
Warum wird das
nicht benutzt, einfach als JSON?
Weil du kein JSON-Pern
schreiben möchtest, sondern Swift.
Also das ist jetzt nicht der Grund, aber ich finde
JSON kacke als Manifest-Format.
Lieber Tommel oder Jammel.
Das finde ich super.
Lieber JSON als Jammel tatsächlich.
Okay, dann ist Tommel ganz oben.
aber ich weigere mich, Jason als
menschengeschriebenes Dateiformat zu akzeptieren.
Jason 5. Ja.
Ist aber gut.
Wo gibt es da für Parser? Nirgends.
Gibt es für JavaScript? Ja, super.
Das ist eine Sprache, die interessiert mich nicht.
Weiß nicht. Also wie finde ich denn hier?
Libraries? Oder wie heißt das?
Libraries.io, oder?
I.O.
Und dann suchen wir mal nach...
Was suche ich jetzt? Jason 5.
JSON-5-Pauser gibt es für Serda.
Kannst du dir in Rust bauen.
Das ist stark.
Kannst du dir für Swift freigeben.
Hast du schon mal eigentlich Swift und Rust in einen Kopf geworfen?
Ich habe mal getestet,
in die Library zu linken,
aber ist schon eine Weile her
und ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wie erfolgreich ich damit war.
Aber da müssen wir uns auch von dem Vincent unterhalten.
Vincent hatte da voller Erfahrung mit.
NSK-JSON gibt es.
NSK-JSON ist a Swift-Library for Pausing Plain-JSON-Format
and JSON-5-Format.
bitteschön
das fängt doch mit NS an
NSK Jason
ist ein Name
aber das ist ja
die API stinkt
kein Codable Support und nichts
gut okay ich glaube jetzt haben wir auch den Bereich
verlassen wo es für die Hörer interessant ist
ähm
ich würde sagen
nachdem wir jetzt
zweieinhalb Stunden aufnehmen.
Autsch, okay. Längere Folge.
Ich meine, heute ist ein Feiertag. Wir könnten den ganzen
Tag aufnehmen, aber... Nein, lass mal nicht noch
drei Stunden über Grau reden.
Vielleicht schneide ich die Folge auch einfach
in der Mitte durch und wir machen 29 und 30
auf.
Nein, nein, auf keinen Fall.
Gut, also ich hoffe, Sascha ist jetzt mittlerweile
in Schweden angekommen, nach zweieinhalb
Stunden Flug.
Wenn er diese Folge während des Fliegens
hört.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen,
wenn du nicht noch einen coolen
Getaps da hast,
dann vielen Dank,
dass ihr euch wieder eine Folge
Akronomisierbar bis zum Ende angehört habt.
Schreibt uns Feedback auf Matrix oder Twitter.
Vorzugreise auf Matrix.
Oder auf Twitter.
Oder natürlich auf
Mastodon.
Ja, stimmt, da gibt es...
Ach Gott, Mastodon habe ich nicht wieder aufgezählt.
Ja, oder schreibt mir, wenn ihr meine Telefonnummer habt,
auf Telegram oder
auf Signal oder auf WhatsApp.
Alles drei Scheiße.
Also ich wäre sehr zufrieden, wenn es einfach nur noch Signal gäbe.
Ii, warum denn gerade die Kack-Plattform?
Warum gerade die Idioten,
die eine Chrome-Package-App als Desktop-App
rausgehauen haben?
Ich weigere mich, Signal zu nutzen. Signal ist eine Scheiße.
Ja, du bist leider der Einzige,
mit dem ich über Wire schreibe.
Ja, du bist auch der Einzige, mit dem ich über Wire schreibe.
Na, es ist halt so.
Manchmal gehe ich aus dem Haus und schreibe mit drei Leuten
und die das machen, wenn ich mit jemandem schreibe.
Ich wechsle ich die
Chat-Anwendung.
Den einen schreibe ich über
Wire, dem anderen über Telegram, dem dritten über Signal,
dem vierten über WhatsApp.
Ich muss sagen, ich präferiere immer noch
WhatsApp über Telegram.
Warum? Weil ich der Krypto da mehr traue.
Du traust Facebook mehr als
einem Unternehmen, die nur einen Messenger bauen.
Tatsächlich ja.
Für mich hat irgendwie
Telegram immer noch diesen fischigen
Kontakte.
Beigeschmack. Die haben halt keine
Krypto-Punkt. WhatsApp?
Nee, Telegram.
Eben. Also, hier
kommt wieder jemand mit, die haben Secretchats.
Oh Gott, wir verändern uns. Also.
Messenger reden wir von anders,
aber fuck alle Messenger.
Ja, am schönsten wäre es sowieso
komplett ohne Messenger.
Weißt du was, wir telefonieren einfach nur noch. Ich ruf dich
einfach immer direkt an, egal ob du
gerade kannst oder nicht.
Das Gesicht.
Also.
das war akronomisierbar
Folge 29
Genießt die, solange wir noch in den
20ern sind. Das war es aber
damit. Das waren die 20er.
Es tut mir leid, es ist vorbei.
Schön, dass du es sagst.
Und der nächste
zufällige Podcast in eurem
Podcatcher beginnt in 3
2 1